Ist ja schon ganz cool geworden hier diese mit der Ebene Raumstation. Wenn nur diese Anzüge nicht so unglaublich figurbetont wären. So, jetzt mal raus zur Aussichtsplattform. Wie ging das noch hier mit dem Schleuse?
So, dann schaust du mal nach ganz links unten in die Ecke.
Ja, sehe ich auch.
Was siehst du da?
Kanadische Inseln, ne? Ich hab meine Brille nicht bei.
Ja, das sind diese Inseln bzw.
Es gibt ja diese ganzen Sicherheitsdinger und la la la. Da kann man sicher seit Jahrzehnten drüber lustig machen. Aber es ist halt eben interessant, wenn man die mal ein bisschen skaliert. Also ich hatte jetzt mal ein Projekt am Finger, wo ich mal in etwas mehr Höhe gearbeitet habe, wo unten Menschen und da drunter sind. Normalerweise auf so einem kleinen Baugerüst an der Hausfront, sitzt man 5 Meter hoch und beim Festschrauben fällt dir eben die Mutter runter. Dann fällt sie halt runter. Das machst du aber nicht, wenn du in mehreren hundert Metern Höhe bist. In mehreren hundert Metern Höhe warst du. Ja, da willst du eben auf deine Schrauben gut aufpassen.
Wo unter dir Menschen sind?
Ja, ich darf das leider noch nicht sagen, wo das war. Aber es gibt so Stellen in Deutschland, wo man so hoch ist und wo unter dir Menschen sind.
Da braucht man WLAN?
Hab ich was von WLAN gesagt? Aber da kann man so mit Technik rumbasteln. Und da wirst du ganz schön ins Zeug genommen von den Sicherheitsinstruktoren dort, was alle mögliche angeht. Du möchtest auch erst recht keinen Schraubenschlüssel runter schmeißen in der Höhe. Egal, ob da jetzt Menschen drauf sind, weil wo der hintrifft, wächst erst mal kein Gras mehr.
Also ich hab absolutes Verständnis für nachvollziehbare Sicherheitsansagen. Aber manchmal gibt es einfach so Situationen, wo sie einfach aus der Verknüpfung der, das ist aber unsere Regel. Und ja, guck mal hier, wie die Realität ist.
Das ist wie, hier nicht rückwärts einparken.
Hier nicht rückwärts einparken.
Hier nicht rückwärts einparken mit Elektroauto.
Wollten wir sagen, also deswegen. Gelegentlich, weil du ja sagst, die haben ja auch so mal, wenn du sagst, ein Raket hatte noch ein paar Meter Höhe.
Ich wollte damit auch nicht sagen, dass auch nur irgendjemand da seinen Ermessensspielraum unangemessen überspannt hat. Ganz im Gegenteil. Die waren ja alle sehr zuvorkommend auf der einen Seite, aber auf der anderen Seite merktest du halt auch, wenn da irgendwie so Security eine Rolle spielt, dann wurde das da auch gnadenlos durchgezogen. Weil wenn die da irgendwas können, dann ist es so Prozesse.
Das sind ja die Europäer.
Nee, das ist auch, glaub ich, Raumfahrt an sich. So erfordert das halt einfach, weil sonst hast du da einfach sofort den Scheiß. Wenn man sich auch anschaut, warum irgendwas...
Ja, aber auch wenn sich so viele Länder zusammenarbeiten, müssen die ja doch durchaus unterschiedliche Temperamente haben in der EU, dann, glaub ich, bist du ganz gut beraten, wenn du gute Prozesse hast, um die Leute alle irgendwie auf Schiene zu halten.
Also, das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Das ganze Projekt ist ja wirklich eine extrem... Also, ich hab... Das fand ich irgendwie auch so prall. Ich meine, du bist ja in Südamerika, gut, offiziell ist das Frankreich. Und du hast da so eine mega internationale Truppe. Aber es sind halt auch alles Europäer, mit extrem wenig Ausnahmen. Einen Amerikaner hab ich da irgendwie wahrgenommen. Mag vielleicht noch einen zweiten geben oder so, aber im Wesentlichen ist es halt alles mit Europäern bestellt.
Ein Euro, ne? Euro gibts da auch. Ein Euroland. Oder Euro-Gengt.
Euro-Roaming.
EU-Roaming?
EU-Roaming. Ich war in Südamerika und konnte irgendwie auf meinem O2-Gigabyte weitersurfen. Das war schon irgendwie ganz cool. Und gab auch Netz und so. Also es war... Ich weiß nicht, hatte ich mal LTE oder 3G?
Wir freuen uns jetzt in 2018 noch darüber, dass es mal Kolonialmächte gab. Wir freuen uns an der Kolonialmacht Frankreichs.
In Surinamen hätte das nicht funktioniert, glaube ich. Das wäre nur eine Etage weiter gewesen.
Naja, aber so das ist...
Ich überlege jetzt gerade, wo du das sagst, ob ich irgendwie sowas wie nennenswerte kulturelle Unterschiede zwischen den Mitarbeitern da... Ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass ich da mit meinem einen Tag, einem vollen Tag Aufenthalt nicht genug Gelegenheit habe, um da wirklich ein umfassendes Bild vor allem zu bekommen. Das war extrem hektisch und man hat z.B. mit vielen geredet. In meiner Kamera beschäftigt, dann auch mal wieder versucht, die Realität einzusaugen. Und dann dieses, wo bin ich eigentlich? Und boah, ist das heiß hier. Das war ja auch die ganze Zeit so schwüle 29 Grad. Das ist ja auch irgendwie eigentlich gar nicht mein Ding. Ja, aber ich glaube, da hat sich schon in den letzten Dekaden... Und das war mir jetzt auch nicht neu. Das kenne ich irgendwie vom ESORG, das kenne ich von der ESA. Alle, die in diesem ganzen ESA, Arianespars, CNES, Circus drin sind, diese ganze europäische Weltraumfahrt, die sind so unfassbar international. Und nicht nur, weil sie dort Int-Email-Adressen haben, sondern einfach, weil sie da das Leben einfach...
Das ist wahrscheinlich beim CERN auch nicht viel anders.
Ja, genau, das ist so diese Wissenschaftler und Ingenieurs-Internationalität, die sich schon so normalisiert hat und die du bei den Astronauten dann nochmal besonders extrem merkst, weil die jetten ja wirklich die ganze Zeit nur quer um den Planeten und heute USA, morgen Russland und dann mal Japan und dann sind wir mal wieder in Paris und dann in Köln. Dass diese dieses ganze Kooperations-Ding einfach so verinnerlicht haben und dass sie auch so unfassbar multilingual alle sind. So wechselt es da wirklich im Sekundentag zwischen Französisch und Englisch und Deutsch. Das ist vollkommen normal. Von daher...
Also insgesamt.
Genau, und die Antwort ist, ich glaube, da hat sich so eine ganz eigene europäische Kultur entwickelt. Das ist gar nicht mehr so die Deutschen und die Franzosen oder so. Ich habe das eher als eine weitere Evolutionsstufe wahrgenommen. Wo das auch irgendwie alles überhaupt gar keine Rolle mehr spielt. Das ist egal. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Thema.
Ich finde, es gibt auch so ein europäisches Englisch. Womit so Native-Speaker nicht klarkommen. Unter anderem verstehen die sich alle, aber so als Native-Speaker, die sagen so, wovon reden die da? Das ist aber komisch.
Ich meine, Engländer gibt es da auch. Ja klar. Das wird doch so bleiben. ESA ist ja kein EU-Projekt. Das ist ja Europa im weiteren Sinne. Es hat ja auch andere Partner, auch internationale Partner.
Finde ich aber okay, abgesehen davon, wie gesagt, von der Koordinalgeschichte, aber naja.
Na ja, dann gab es ja noch diese Anomalie, die weitere Anomalie. Das war ja dann auch insofern was Besonderes, als dass ja ausgerechnet dieser Start dann auch ein bisschen schiefgegangen ist. Nachdem jetzt wirklich seit ewigen Zeiten gar nichts schiefgegangen ist, ist in diesem Mal ja das erste Mal wieder ein bisschen was dazwischen geraten.
War das denn bei denen oder war das wieder das Device hinten, war ja bei dem Ding vor 14 Tagen da, SpaceX, irgendwie dieser geheime Zoomer-Satellit dahinter irgendwie.
Ja, aber da weiß man ja nichts genaues.
Ja, aber irgendwie die Air Force hat jetzt nochmal gesagt, nee, nee, das war die Payload, die da schiefgegangen ist. Irgendein Air Force Official hat das gesagt. Aber da reiben sich auch noch die Köpfe, die Leute, die eh mal gegen SpaceX sind, da haben sich schon die Hände geregnet und haben gesagt, jetzt haben die einen schönen, teuren Staatssatelliten irgendwie ins Nirwana gekickt. Aber die Air Force meint jetzt doch nicht und hin und her. Das war ja ein großes Politikum damals auch. Weil SpaceX durfte ja nicht sagen, was da wie drauf ist, da haben wir gesagt, ja unser Ding ist dahin geflogen und hin wollte, hat tschüss gesagt und ist wieder nach Hause gekommen. Der Teil, der nach Hause kommen sollte. So, fertig, peng. Da ist jetzt eine spannende Frage, wie ist das da bei dem Ariane-Ding?
Genau, weiß man da schon mehr oder?
Also vielleicht zunächst einmal, was ist eigentlich passiert? Also es gab halt diesen Start, da waren zwei Satelliten drauf. Ich glaube, ein, oh Gott, ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, ein Kommunikationssatellit, ein amerikanischer und das andere war das arabisches Ding, ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht. Das sind so Dinge, mit denen ich mich ehrlich gesagt im Vorfeld gar nicht groß beschäftigt habe, weil meine Konzentration irgendwie auf was anderem lag. Wie auch immer, das Ding ist hochgegangen und offenbar hat die Ariane 5 nicht den richtigen Kurs genommen. Und das führte dann dazu, dass die Satelliten zwar im Kern auf der richtigen Höhe gelandet sind, aber nicht in der richtigen Neigung.
Also Bahnneigung gegen Äquator.
Bahnneigung gegen Äquator, also wenn du 0 Grad hast, dann fliegst du quasi direkt über dem Äquator.
Kann man ja noch mit Verhältnis, also im Verhältnis zu dem anderen Problem verhältnismäßig wenig Sprit wieder in den Griff kriegen, oder? Wenn die Höhe scheiße ist, ist es immer blöd, weil eine Menge Sprit kostet.
Wenn die Höhe scheiße ist, ist es blöd. Wenn die Neigung scheiße ist, musst du auch Sprit zum Einsatz bringen. Also du musst dich irgendwie woanders hin beschleunigen.
Ja, das verkürzt natürlich die Lebensdauer der Mission.
Ja und nein, also ich habe mit einem Menschen, der etwas näher an diesem Prozess war, gesprochen. Und natürlich konnten die einem jetzt auch vieles auch erst mal noch nicht sagen, schlicht und ergreifend, weil das natürlich jetzt erst mal noch untersucht werden muss. Die haben jetzt eine Untersuchungskommission gestartet. Und es gab dann halt Sprachregelungen und Pressemitteilungen etc. Im Kern ist jetzt erst mal die Situation die gewesen, dass die halt nicht auf der richtigen Neigung waren. Und es so ist, dass Satelliten, die halt über so ein Ionentriebwerk verfügen, was wohl heutzutage schon recht verbreitet ist, die können halt im Prinzip ohne richtig Sprit zu verbrauchen, das Ganze...
Oder nicht mehr Sprit zu verbrauchen.
Ja, die brauchen nur mehr Zeit. Also die setzen das dann einfach mit Strom in Beschleunigung um und dann sind sie halt mal vier Wochen dabei, das auszugleichen und dann sind sie halt irgendwie da. Und bei denen, die halt Sprit nur haben mit Düsen, die machen dann halt... und sind dann irgendwie wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schneller da, dauert natürlich auch ein bisschen Zeit, aber haben natürlich dann etwas Spritverbrauch, den sie vielleicht so nicht hätten verbrauchen wollen. Nur ist es wohl so, dass die Reserven, die heutzutage in den Satelliten eingeplant werden, also brauchst du im Prinzip... Erstmal brauchst du natürlich den Sprit, den du meinst für deine voraussichtliche Betriebszeit zu brauchen, den musst du halt an Bord haben. Dann brauchst du zusätzlich noch den Sprit, den du brauchst, um dich bei der Dekommissionierung des Gerätes wegzulassen.
Also das erste ist die Bahndegratation, der du entgegenwirkst. Weil du hast ja immer so ein ganz bisschen... hast ja noch Luftwiderstand und den musst du ja ausgleichen. Davon redest du jetzt im ersten Punkt.
Ähm, genau.
Da wollte ich nur sicher gehen.
Genau, den Sprit, den du einfach brauchst, um dich immer wieder auch an der richtigen Stelle zu halten, weil das ist nicht so der perfekte Ort, den du einmal triffst, und dann bleibt das auf Ewigkeiten so. Sondern du hast halt so Partikel und was weiß ich.
Da musst du dann auch Waldraummüll ausweichen.
Genau, da musst du dann auch Müll ausweichen.
Ach so, den hast du aber auch unter dem ersten Punkt subsummiert.
Genau. Das ist so das, was man so üblicherweise so meihen zu brauchen. So plus, dann musst du halt noch die Dekommissionierung, also wenn das Ding dann außer Betrieb genommen wird. Das sind ja in dem Fall waren das ja beides geostationäre Satelliten, die halt bei 36.000 Kilometer werden.
Die in den Park Orbit geschoben werden, noch ein Stück nach oben.
Genau, die werden dann ein bisschen weiter rausgeschoben, da ist dann sozusagen Friedhof und da ist dann irgendwie gut. Und diese Spritrechnung ist sozusagen angelegt für Minimum, was wir eben oben bleiben wollen, plus x. Und dieses plus x ist sozusagen, was passiert im Falle einer Verlängerung der Mission. Was ist, wenn wir noch mal zwei Jahre dranhängen müssen oder so. Weil üblicherweise werden viele dieser Satelliten dann einfach im Rahmen eines technologischen Updates ausgetauscht. Nach zehn Jahren ist dann einfach so ein Kommunikationssatellit auch nicht mehr up to date, bzw. du willst den dann einfach durch neue Möglichkeiten etc. ersetzen und so. Das heißt, kann sehr gut sein, dass dieser zusätzliche Spritaufwand, um jetzt diese Bahn zu erreichen, am Ende noch nicht mal die reguläre Laufzeit nennenswert einschränkt. Erschränkt nur die potenzielle Verlängerung ein.
So was ähnliches war doch auch bei dem Galileo-Satelliten, der auf der Soyuz drauf war.
Aber der war dann zu niedrig, glaube ich.
Den hatten sie, glaube ich, noch mal in eine nutzbare Bahn heben können.
Ja, aber nicht in die eigentliche, die sie haben wollten. Die haben sich da jetzt irgendwas ausgedacht, für was man ihn jetzt noch verwenden kann, aber so hundertprozentig glücklich sind sie damit.
Na ja, okay. Also ganz so schlimm war es nicht.
Es war nicht schön, aber es war zumindest kein Totalverlust. Am Ende kannst du damit auch irgendwas testen und Dinge tun und so weiter. Dann hast du halt so einen Teil zum kaputt machen. Ist ja irgendwie auch ganz nett. Aber ich hab da jetzt ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig Kenntnisse, was sie da bei Galileo jetzt mitgemacht haben. Ich hatte nur so ein paar zwischenzeitliche Sachen mitbekommen, die ich jetzt nicht weiter verfolgt habe. Ja, das war das. Die waren aber auch ganz cool irgendwie. Also es war schon so, ja, scheiße gelaufen. Müssen wir uns jetzt genauer anschauen.
Aber ja, warum auch nicht?
Hätte schlimmer kommen können, nächste Mal. Also die waren so unbeunruhigt, dass sie die nächsten Staats nicht verschoben haben. Das sagt schon mal was aus. Also wenn jetzt so richtig Explosion oder irgendwas ganz Schlimmes passiert wäre. Ich vermute mal, dass, oder sagen wir mal so, Leute vermuten, ja, also als ob ich das beurteilen könnte. Kann ich nicht, aber Leute, die mit mir gesprochen haben, hatten eher die Vermutung, dass es sich hierbei schlicht um eine Fehlprogrammierung handelt. Also es ist kein Versagen der Hardware, sondern dass hier irgendwie einfach, warum auch immer, wodurch auch immer ausgelöst, einfach die falsche Bahn gewählt wurde. Also ein Software-Fuck-Up könnte man sagen, vielleicht, vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht auch ein Daten-Fuck-Up oder eine Kombination aus beiden, weiß ich nicht. Das wird man sicherlich noch rausbekommen. Aber zumindest ist nichts explodiert. Wäre aber noch schöner gewesen, hätte ich ja noch nicht mal meinen Besuch dadurch ziehen können. So viel aus Kourou, erstmal.
Ist darstellbar. Ich war ja mal im August auf Jamaika, ich kann das nicht weiter empfehlen. Da hast du so 32 bis 35 Grad. Bei gefühlt 120 Prozent Luftfeuchtigkeit, das will man nicht.
Das ist auch kein Spaß. Aber die Leute kann sich daran gewöhnen. Also für drei Tage ist das krass. Ich kann mir das auch gut vorstellen. Wenn du jetzt nur ein oder zwei Tage da warst, hast du keine Chance, dich zu akklimatisieren.
Es ist mir in fünf Wochen nicht gelungen, mich da richtig zu akklimatisieren. Aber naja, ist halt nicht mein Ding.
Ich hab jetzt schon viel erzählt.
Soll ich mal ein bisschen was erzählen?
Mach mal.
Du hattest auch noch so eine kleine Anomalie.
Ich hatte auch eine Anomalie. Die Anomalie war ein weißer VW-Bus aus Cottbus.
Das sagt ja schon allen eigentlich.
Und zwar, der hatte eine Bahnanomalie in einem sein denkbar schlechten Zeitpunkt. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob der überhaupt programmiert war. Auf jeden Fall hatte ich den dann vor der Motorhaube.
Und dein sechs Tage alter Zoe ist Schrott.
Naja, er war ja nicht sechs Tage alt. Ich hatte ihn sechs Tage, er war ja drei Jahre alt.
Ja, aber aus deiner Perspektive war er sechs Tage alt.
Aus meiner Perspektive war er dann, und auch aus der Perspektive des Sachverständigen, war er dann ein Totalschaden. Naja, was soll ich sagen? Also ein BMW-Fahrer, der hinter dem VW-Bus fuhr, der hat dann direkt erstmal Polizei und Krankenwagen und alles in Gang gesetzt.
Die hast du dich von einem Verbrennerfahrer retten lassen müssen.
So sieht es wohl aus. Das sah so komisch aus. Beide Airbags sind ja losgegangen. Dann war natürlich erstmal Rauch im Auto, weil die Airbags ja mit so einer Treibladung.
Die sind ja auch noch eingestaubt, damit sie nicht zusammenkleben.
Genau, und dann war ich so, brennt es jetzt, muss ich mir sorgen, um den Akku zu machen oder so. Nicht so schlimm. Es ist wie bei der Kissen-Schlacht, wenn man ordentlichen Kissen ins Gesicht kriegt.
Hast du dich jetzt mehr darüber erschreckt, dass hier jemand vorne reingefahren ist, oder hast du dich mehr...
Erschreckt habe ich mich gar nicht. Ich hab den nur fahren sehen, dachte, oh Scheiße, auf die Bremse gedrückt, und dann war es halt schon vorbei. Also das war so...
Und der Airbag, ging wann los?
Als es rumsste.
Ja, bei O, bei Scheiße?
Nach, oh Scheiße. Und dann rums. Und bei rums ging auch der Airbag los.
Die gefühlte Zeit zwischen Rums und Knall. Also war das so instantan?
Mehr oder weniger. Also ich hab den Airbag auch gar nicht so richtig mitgekriegt.
Der ist so schneller wieder weg, ne?
Ja, das macht so Rums, man rückt natürlich nach vorne, wenn man diesen Stoß bekommt, dann hängt man wieder hinten am Sitz. Und dann pfeift es erstmal im Ohr, weil das Ding halt laut ist. Und das war's dann im Wesentlichen. Dann hab ich den Gurt aufgemacht, Tür auf, bin ausgestiegen. Mehr war er erstmal nicht.
Du bist in einer neuen Welt.
Dann stand ich da irgendwie etwas verdattert und total verwirrt. Und so, äh, und jetzt und wie und Scheiße und Frost. Dann kam irgendwann die Polizei und der Krankenwagen. Die vom Krankenwagen haben mich gleich Halskrause um. Irgendwie, hier kommen sie mal mit, da aufs Bett legen. Zack, bumm, festschneid, Krankenhaus. Zwischendrin, ja okay, das hat ein bisschen länger gedauert. Aber zwischendrin kam dann noch mal der Polizist an. Und meinte so, ja, hier und abschleppen und so. Und ich so, ja, sollen wir jemanden rufen? Und ich so, ja, was sollste da sagen? Ja, dann rufen sie jemanden, so nach der Art. Dann kam noch die Feuerwehr. Dann hieß es noch, die Feuerwehr weiß nicht so richtig, was sie machen soll, ist ja ein Elektroauto. Was so geil war, weil irgendwie das Auto stand da halt mit jede Menge kaputtem Plastik, was da rumlag. Aber ansonsten, also, sagen wir mal, von der Windschutzscheibe aus nach hinten sah es halt nicht so aus, als wäre da irgendwas passiert. Also Scheibe noch ganz und Tür ging ganz normal auf und so weiter. Und der VW-Bus sah nicht so aus, als wäre ihm viel passiert, aber es liefen halt diverse Flüssigkeiten aus die Straße, aus diesem VW-Bus raus irgendwie. Irgendwie das war echt irgendwie komisch.
Flüssigkeiten hast du nicht so viel.
Nee, Bremsleitung blieb wohl ganz. Und ansonsten...
Waschwasser.
Bremsflüssigkeit, Waschwasser. Mehr Flüssigkeiten sind im Elektroauto nicht. Na ja, gut, die Klimaanlage noch. Aber das blieb irgendwie alles ganz.
War dir der andere Wagen so physikalisch mehr zerstört als deiner?
Nee, also... Wie gesagt, ein VW-Bus hat halt mehr Masse. Nach Impulserhaltung kriegt halt der, der weniger Masse hat, mehr ab. Deswegen...
Na gut, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie groß er war. Aber er war mehr kaputt, was so......siffendes Zeug betracht.
Er sah halt... Stell dir einen VW-Bus vor, der vorne irgendwie zehn Zentimeter eingedellt ist oder so.
Also hat er dich auch mit der Front erwischt, sozusagen.
Front an Front. Genau.
So aber so leicht schräg, oder?
Ja, leicht schräg. Der ist halt links abgebogen, mir quasi direkt vor die Nase gefahren. Und dann hab ich ihn halt, äh, ja. Zerlegt. Naja, zerlegt.
Kraft ist Masse, mal Beschleunigung.
Kraft ist Masse, mal Beschleunigung. Genau.
Warst du jetzt auch nicht so schnell unterwegs?
Normal 40, 50 so in der Art.
Das hätt ich jetzt auch gesagt.
Ja, aber du kommst da so aus so einem Kreisel raus und dann ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 30 Meter weiter die Ampel, die halt da auf grün war.
Okay, also hat sich zumindest keiner... Es war klar, dass das nicht deine Schuld war.
Also sagen wir mal so, die... Also dieser VW-Bus ist irgendwie von so einem Malereibetrieb... Keine Ahnung, zwei Handwerkertypen da in dem VW-Bus drin. Die waren wahrscheinlich irgendwie auf Montage, wollten dann 6 Uhr abends nach Feierabend zurück nach Cottbus, um dann das Auto abzugeben und irgendwann mal zu Hause zu sein. Die hatten es wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen eilig, naja, eilig, aber sie waren wahrscheinlich, wollten halt einfach nach Hause. Ich wollte ja auch einfach nach Hause. Bin ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 300 Meter vorher weggefahren mit vollem Akku. Also das Auto steht jetzt da in Potsdam auf dem Abschleppschrottplatz.
Mit Strom drin.
Mit Strom. Der Akku ist voll. Also der ist komplett voll irgendwie.
Aber du hast jetzt auch nicht versucht, ihn zu bewegen oder so. Also ich meine...
Nee, das Auto hat ja dadurch, dass es, also es hat die Airbags gezündet, hat dadurch direkt gemerkt, dass irgendwie... Dass alles nicht mehr stimmt, hat von sich aus die Warnblinkanlage angemacht. Und direkt auch, ich glaub, die Parkbremse angemacht. Und man konnte auch den Ganghebel nicht mehr... Also Ganghebel. Also diesen komischen, was so aussieht wie ein Automatikganghebel, aber nur ein Schalter ist, wo man halt umschaltet, ob man nach vorne, nach hinten oder gar nicht fährt. Und was das Bekloppteste ist, da geht dann so ein... Im Display, was hinter dem Lenkrad ist, wie nennt man dieses Display? Egal. Da ist auf der rechten Seite, in der Ecke, der Kilometerstand. Und über diesem Kilometerstand zeigt er also dann an. Warnung, elektrisches System kaputt oder irgendwie sowas. Elektrische Störung Gefahr. Stopp, elektrische Störung Gefahr. Ein großer roter, rote Kiste, die da vor dem Kilometerstand steht. Und der Sachverständige fragte mich dann so ein bisschen flehendlich, ob ich wüsste, wie man jetzt den Kilometerstand von einem Auto abliest, weil man könnte ja nichts sehen, da ist ja die Warnung von dem Kilometerstand.
Das ist für jeden wichtig oder was?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Vor allen Dingen der Rest von dem Display ist halt leer. Also irgendwie, man hätte die Warnung auch woanders hin machen können. Na ja gut, dann war ich einen Tag im Krankenhaus. Die haben mich halt irgendwie ans EKG angeschlossen für 24 Stunden.
Ach echt?
Ja, bei so einem Frontalzusammenstoß hast du halt schnell den Verdacht, dass du Verletzungen innerer Organe hast. Und gebrochene Rippen und all diesen ganzen Krämpel, das haben sie aber alles nicht gefunden. Also das einzige ist halt fürchterliche Nacken. Jaja, genau.
Aber Nacken hast du schon gehabt?
Nacken hab ich, das hab ich immer noch.
Wie äußert sich das so?
Das äußert sich darin, dass ich immer noch Nackenverspannungen hab. Also besonders morgens nach dem Schlafen, das irgendwie, da kann ich mich kaum bewegen. Also das ist aber...
Trotz Gurt, Nackenstütze und Airbag. Und an welcher der beiden Bewegungen war das sozusagen schuld?
Keine Ahnung, kann ich dir nicht sagen. Also das ist wahrscheinlich einfach vielleicht auch so ein Verkrampfen im Schreck. Und dann wird aber der Kopf trotzdem hin und her befördert. Kann ich dir nicht genau sagen.
Und solange wird dich das wohl verfolgen?
Ja, es wird schon besser. Also ich mach halt Physio und dann... Ach Gottchen. Ja, sechs Tage hatte ich das Auto. Nicht mal eine ganze Woche. Und jetzt? Und das, wo ich das 600 Kilometer aus München mit sieben Ladestops hierher gefahren hab. Na, das Wetter war nicht so schlecht.
Okay, aber kalt?
Kalt war's, ja. Aber es war jetzt nicht so wie bei Timo, als er seinen E-Golf abgeholt hat, dass er dann mitten in einen Schneesturm gekommen ist. Also, das war es nicht, aber es war, ja. Und ja, das Auto ist Schrott, aber und jetzt kommt das große, was mich die letzten Tage echt total genervt hat. Und zwar, normalerweise ist es ja so, das Auto wird dann vom Gutachter geschätzt und dann macht die Versicherung irgendwas.
Ja, jetzt hast du es ja gerade vor sechs Tagen gekauft.
Moment, jetzt ist in dem Auto aber eine Batterie drin, die mir nicht gehört, weil das eine Leihbatterie ist von Renault. Das heißt... Du siehst es schon kommen, genau. Das heißt, da muss jetzt jemand mit Sachverstand nochmal die Batterie angucken. Diese Leute gibt es aber nur bei Renault, an den entsprechenden Renault-Stützpunkten oder bei größeren Renault-Händlern, die dafür zertifiziert sind. Jetzt hat der Gutachter versucht da jemanden zu finden und hat erst beim tollen Autohaus hier in Berlin angerufen. Renault-König. Und die haben gesagt, ja, ne, aber mal in der Filiale Entelto nachfragen. Da hat die Filiale Entelto gesagt, ne, ne, Haupthaus, das machen wir hier nicht. Und dann ging es eine Weile hin und her, dann wollten sie ihn zu dem Renault-Stützpunkt in Belitz schicken, weil, ja, war ja in Brandenburg und so.
Das ist Kartoffel, ne? Es fährt jetzt nicht mehr, es zählt keine Sau mehr. Da fasst man nicht mehr an, das Auto.
So, und dann hat er wohl dann bei der Renault-Bank nochmal angerufen und hin und her. Und okay, jetzt ist der Renault-Stützpunkt in Tempelhof geworden. Aber jetzt kommt's. Die Renault-Bank, die dir die Batterie vermietet, interessiert es aber nicht, was mit der Batterie passiert. So nach der Art, sie müssen jetzt gucken, wie sie das Auto zu diesem Stützpunkt kriegen, damit die da drüber gucken können. Sonst lassen wir sie nicht aus dem Vertrag. Schönen Batteriemietvertrag haben sie da. Wäre doch schade, wenn sie da nicht rauskommen würden.
Du meinst, für den Schadensfall, da gibt es keinerlei...
Das interessiert die nicht. Ich weiß es nicht, da steht bestimmt was drin. Wie das so ist mit 20 Seiten dünn gedrucktem Liga-Lies, das liest ja keiner. Oder hast du die iTunes-Geheimnachbaren gelesen?
Ich singe die immer abends meinen Kindern zum Einschlaf vor.
Alter Scheiter.
Moment, jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz drüber nachdenken. Also, das Ding ist jetzt sozusagen nicht in deinem Besitz. Und deswegen kann der Gutachter das nicht begutachten, wie der Schaden ist. Oder der kann es deshalb nicht machen, weil es einfach ein komischer Elektroakku ist und keinerlei Fähigkeit hat, das zu beurteilen.
Genau, er kann es nicht beurteilen, sondern die Renault-Werkstatt kann nur den Akku durchmessen. Dazu muss das Auto aber wohl zu Renault gebracht werden, weil Renault dann den Akku ausbauen kann, den auf Herz und Nieren testen kann und sagen kann, wie viel das kostet, den zu reparieren oder ob er Totalschaden hat.
Und was wollen Sie dann danach damit machen?
Der Mann von der Renault-Bank meinte zu mir, es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass der Akku ein Totalschaden ist. So was passiert eigentlich nur, wenn das Auto abbrennt oder bei einem Wasserschaden. Ansonsten kann man die in der Regel reparieren, meinte er.
Wenn es überhaupt kaputt ist.
Also in der Regel ist es billiger, die Batterie zu reparieren, als sie zu ersetzen.
Nee, aber hat sie überhaupt einen Schaden?
Das weiß ich ja nicht.
Okay, das weißt du nicht, aber wo ist denn dieser Akku? Der ist doch nicht in diesem Bereich, wo dieser Vorfall stattfand vorne.
Nein, aber trotzdem behauptet ja das Auto, dass es ein elektrisches Problem gäbe und da Gefahr sei. Und überhaupt wäre das eine Standardprozedur und das müsste gemacht werden.
Ja klar, das haben wir schon immer so gemacht.
Aber man kann eigentlich, also man würde doch jetzt meinen, als durchschnittlich begabter Freak Show Team-Teilnehmer, dass man das Akkuteil, das irgendwie überlebt haben müsste eigentlich. Oder ist da irgendwas noch vorgefallen, was tatsächlich naheliegt, dass da irgendwas dran kaputt gehen kann? Weil das war unten und wahrscheinlich in der Mitte.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das Akkupack mindestens mal zerbogen hat. Also eigentlich ist die Fahrgastzelle ganz geblieben, aber ob die jetzt auf den Millimeter genau noch die Maße hat, die sie haben soll, wenn das Auto das Werk verlässt, das würde ich jetzt nicht umsetzen. Das würde ich unbedingt annehmen, keine Ahnung.
Okay, das heißt, du musst jetzt irgendwie einen Weg finden, wie das Schrottteil, du musst ja den ganzen Schrottwagen dahin fahren. Darfst du das überhaupt?
Nein, der fährt ja nicht mehr.
Nein, aber du kannst ihn ja hin transportieren lassen.
Ja, jetzt kommt die nächste Stufe. Also es gibt ja so Abschleppunternehmen, die schleppen dann ab. Dann steht es bei denen auf dem Hof. Und dann kostet das pro Tag, dass das da auf dem Hof steht, zumindest bei dem, wo das jetzt steht, halt 10 Euro.
Wie wird bezahlt?
Eigentlich die Versicherung. Aber der lässt das Auto nicht wieder vom Hof, bevor es nicht bezahlt wurde oder eine Versicherung gesagt hat, dass sie es auf jeden Fall bezahlen wird.
Genau.
Es wird noch viel besser. Dadurch, dass ich das ja erst bezahlen kann, wenn ich eine Rechnung habe. Aber die Rechnung ja erst fertig gemacht werden kann, wenn klar ist, wie viele Tage das Teil auf dem.
Aber die können sich nicht einfach eine Rechnung für bis zu vier Tage bis morgen?
Doch, das hab ich jetzt gemacht. Hab die angerufen, hab gesagt, Jungs, mach die Rechnung, hier schickt die mir per Mail und dann überweis ich das heute noch und dann kommt das Ding nach Tempelhof.
Und dann musst du jetzt noch mal den Abschleppwagen bezahlen, der das Teil jetzt nach Tempelhof fährt und dann haushältst du diesem Renault-Händler ein kaputtes Auto hin, dass die sich dann anschauen.
Ja, der Renault-Händler wiederum, also der Renault-Stützpunkt. Also ich hab mit dem telefoniert vor zwei Tagen und gut, ich hatte jetzt keine Videotelefonie, aber durch den Hörer konnte man schon sehen, dass er mich anguckt wie ein Mondkalb.
Man hat gehört, das leise Munen des Mondkalbs.
Man hat schon gehört, wovon redest du her? Ach so, ja, schaffen Sie einen Wagen her. Und ich so, soll ich den einfach auf den Hof stellen lassen? Ja, ja, machen Sie mal. Na gut, dann ist es jetzt so. Jetzt hab ich dem Abschlepper nochmal die Nummer von dem Renault-Sstützpunkt gegeben. Und ich hoffe, dass die das morgen irgendwie gebacken kriegen, dass das Teil da irgendwie aufschlägt. Und dann schauen wir mal.
Aber das kriegen Sie ja gar nicht auf Ihre komische Rampe gefahren. Und so brauchen Sie ja selber einen Gabelstopp.
Der Abschlepper hat das Teil vom Unfallort auf seinen Hof gebracht. Der wird das von seinem Hof auf den Hof...
Nee, der Abschlepper schon, aber wenn es dann erstmal bei Renault ist, habe ich ein bisschen Zweifel, dass Renault in der Lage ist, diesen Wagen zu bewegen. Weil die sind ja vielleicht ausreichend vorbereitet. Du weißt es nicht. Aber du hast ihnen schon gesagt, dass er eigentlich nicht fährt.
Ja, also...
Sag nur, vielleicht kann man ja schon die nächste Verpeilungsstufe etwas eindämmen, indem man da irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Ach, weißt du, dann dürfen die jetzt mal eine Runde leiten. Also...
Nicht, dass die dir dann auch noch Geld dafür berechnen, dass das Ding da rumsteht. Ich meine, die haben doch auch Kosten dadurch. Tragen die das zumindest selber?
Ja, am Ende des Tages muss das sowieso die gegnerische Versicherung zahlen. Weil die hat den gesamten Schaden, also deren Kunde hat ja den gesamten Schaden erzeugt. Was halt unklar ist, mir zumindest, ist halt, ob Renault jetzt als Geschädigter der Batterie auch den Transport von dem Auto zum Renault-Stützpunkt als Schädigung, bei der Versicherung geltend macht und ich dann mein Geld von Renault kriege. Oder ob ich das dir... Das ist alles... Ja, ich hab mir zwar einen Anwalt genommen, aber von dem hab ich bisher nichts mehr gehört. Also das ist irgendwie auch so.
Ich brauch so einen Spezialisten im Bereich Elektroautos, die im Straßenverkehr zu Schrott gefahren werden.
Du, ich bin bald selber einer.
Ich seh schon, erste Staatsprüfung hast du bald durch.
Also ich war eine Woche krankgeschrieben, in der hab ich gefühlt nichts anderes gemacht, als mit Leuten zu telefonieren, um herauszufinden, wie denn das jetzt funktioniert. Weil ich war da natürlich auch unbeleckt. Und irgendwie, da hab ich da in Kaiserslautern bei der Renault Bank angerufen. Und dann war da so ein freundlicher Genosse da am Apparat und der hat nicht aufgehört zu reden. Überhaupt nicht, der war auch nicht zu unterbrechen. Und hat irgendwie mir alles, was ich schon aus vorhergehenden Telefonaten wusste, alles noch mal erzählt. Und zwar doppelt hält besser.
Naja, wäre es immer furchtbar, wenn man mit dieser realen Welt da draußen tatsächlich interagieren muss.
Ja, also inzwischen bin ich über diesen ganzen Hessel so genervt, dass der Verlust des Autos irgendwie schon extrem in den Hintergrund gerückt ist. Aber ich...
Abweckungsmanöver.
Ich bin auch ernsthaft am Überlegen, ob ich noch mal eine Leihbatterie haben will. Das ist irgendwie... Ich weiß nicht.
Also unter diesem Gesichtspunkt mit was passiert eigentlich im Schadensfall, habe ich das auch ehrlich gesagt noch nicht durchdacht.
Das ist... Da wird der Amtsschimmel.
Vor allen Dingen, sie bieten einen...
Aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen bestellter Amtsschimmel.
Vor allen Dingen, sie bieten halt einem so irgendwie so eine, weiß nicht, ob das jetzt Mobilitätsgarantie...
Rundum-Glücklicht-Paket.
Heißt oder so, ja, wenn du mit dem Teil liegen bleibst, weil, weiß ich nicht, Ladesäule kaputt und du schaffst das zu keiner anderen oder so, dann kommen sie vorbei und laden dir das Teil auf. Aber wenn du einen Unfall gebaut hast, dass sie das Teil abholen und zum Händler bringen, das bieten sie dir nicht an. Also das verstehe ich auch überhaupt nicht. Das interessiert dir halt dann gar nicht mehr.
Du sagst doch nicht, dass das Auto kaputt ist. Du sagst einfach, ja, ich habe hier ein Ladeproblem. Kann das hier gerade nicht laden, das Auto bewegt sich nicht mehr. Bring sie mir das mal in die nächste Läufe. Wenn sie dann ankommen, dann da sehen, dann...
Ja, aber der Akku ist ja voll.
This Day sagt nur, es gibt elektrische Probleme. Keine Ahnung, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wo das herkommt.
Ja, schauen sie mal, wie der Wagen hier vorne aussieht.
Och, das habe ich ja noch gar nicht gesehen.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, der Akku ist doch voll. Naja, so ist der Stand der Dinge.
Stellt sich ja jetzt die Frage, willst du eigentlich noch mal eine haben?
Die Zoe an sich ist ein korrektes Auto zu einem korrekten Preis. Kann man eigentlich nichts sagen. Aber das mit der Leihbatterie, das muss ich mir jetzt noch mal eine Runde durch den Kopf gehen lassen, ob ich...
Du glaubst jetzt, die ist auch vorgeschrieben oder was? Es gab ja mal eine Zeit, da war das so das einzige Geschäftsmodell, glaube ich.
Ja, und die ganz Alten haben auch noch nicht das Geschäftsmodell umgestellt. Also wenn du jetzt eine neue Zoe kaufen würdest, könntest du die Batterie kaufen, so wie ich weiß.
Ich dachte, das wäre andersrum gewesen.
Aber bei den gebrauchten Zoys, die gibt es halt nur mit der Leihbatterie.
Und das ist sozusagen das, was dich zurückhalten würde. Aber also an sich, die Sextage Experience war jetzt so schlecht nicht?
Nö, war sie nicht. Also klar, das Auto hat Macen, so wie soll ich sagen, Dinge, die einem nicht so gefallen natürlich irgendwie. Also dieses Navigationssystem. Also man hat in der Mitte so ein Display, wie groß wird das sein? Vielleicht so groß wie ein iPad Mini. Ah, sagen wir mal zwischen einem normalen iPad und einem iPad Mini, so in der Größe, Touchscreen. Natürlich keine Retina-Auflösung, aber scheiß drauf. Und da ist immer mindestens zwei Drittel davon ist Navigation. Das kannst du nicht ausschalten. Also man kann zwar die Home Screen quasi konfigurieren, aber du kannst das Navigationsgerät nicht ausschalten. Das ist aber jetzt nicht so toll, dass man es unbedingt benutzen wollen würde. Also ich meine, das ist ja bei den meisten Herstellern so, dass du das eingebaute Navi nicht benutzen möchtest. Also deswegen hast du immer irgendwo deine Handyhalterung am Start und hast da halt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, was drauf. Da gibt es ja verschiedene Lösungen, die gut funktionieren. Und dann würde man halt gerne das Navi wegkonfigurieren können. Aber nein, zwei Drittel sind immer fest verbaut für dieses Navi. Das ist so eine der Sachen. Ansonsten, das passt schon.
Kann es nicht. Jetzt die spannende Frage.
Aber es gibt ein Hack für Android Auto. Ja, also das Radio geht zumindest nicht von alleine an.
So mit ausmachen und aussteigen, weggehen, wiederkommen, Tür aufmachen und das immer noch aus? Das geht bei mir nicht. Das ist mein einziger großer Schmerz, den ich habe an dem Tesla. Ansonsten bin ich total happy mit dem Ding. Aber es geht mir so tierisch auf die Ketten, dass das Ding immer Radar machen muss.
Wie, das Radio geht immer an oder ist immer an?
Sie haben das in einem Gerät, was durchaus mal den einen oder anderen Dollar kostet und in 2017 hergestellt wurde, haben sie es nicht geschafft, das so zu machen, dass sie sich den letzten State merken kann.
Meinst du jedes Mal, wenn du den Wagen wieder in Betrieb nimmst, geht automatisch das Radio an?
Naja, irgendwas, es macht halt irgendeinen Krach. Das ist halt das Tolle daran. Was ich merken kann, ist die Lautstärke. Aber ich denke natürlich nicht dran, vor dem Aussteigen extra nochmal die Lautstärke auf Null zu reden. Also pass auf, du steigst jetzt ein, hörst dort Podcast. Podcast-Frag, da das Ding keinen Podcast-Client hat. Das spielt zwar irgendwelche Web-Radios und all möglichen anderen Scheiß, aber podcast spiele ich von meinem Telefon per Bluetooth. Ja, so, dann manchmal, wenn ich mit meiner Freundin durch die Gegend fahre, spielt sie auch einen Podcast von ihrem Telefon. So, jetzt steigen wir beide aus, gehen weg, Auto zu, hinaus, komme irgendwann alleine wieder, macht das Auto auf, sagt das Auto sich, ja, dann lass mal den Podcast weiterspielen. Oh, das Telefon meiner Freundin ist ja gar nicht mehr da. Naja, dann muss ich ja irgendeinen anderen Krach machen. Dann sagt er nicht so aus oder geht nicht, sondern dann macht er halt irgendwas. Manchmal versucht er sich dann mein Telefon und drückt einfach auf die Play-Taste, dann ist immer irgendeine Sound-Up, die gerade zuletzt vorne war, fängt dann an zu spielen.
Dann war wahrscheinlich der erste Titel, der Alphabet sortierte in der Library.
Oder wenn er ganz verzweifelt ist, macht er einfach das Radio an. Und es ist mir doch auch scheißegal, ob der auf der Frequenz wat ist oder nicht. Das heißt, wenn ich aufs Land rausfahre und hab hier halt vorher irgendwie so einen Lokalsender gehört hier, der macht dann draußen auf dem brandnurrischen Land nur noch... Scheißegal, das heißt machst du diese Tür von dem Auto, setzt dich rein und dann nach einer Sekunde so... Und das ist auch egal, ob ich vorher versucht habe, es gibt keinen Ausknopf. Du kannst halt den Inputselektor, das heißt, kannst du jetzt Bluetooth vom Telefon spielen, auch von welchem Telefon, oder Blickradio hören, oder DAB, oder das hat ja auch so ein eingebautes Webradio, das funktioniert auch ganz gut.
DAB-Empfänger ist da auch drin?
Und wie gesagt, dieses Webradio, was auch da für um ist, das kannst du halt alle möglichen Webradio-Stationen dir da anhören, das funktioniert auch sehr gut alles. Aber es gibt halt keine Selektion, die sagt, nee, ich will jetzt mal nix hören. So nix. Und bitte merkt ihr das, wenn ich aussteige, einkomme, möchte ich immer noch nix hören. So, der ist halt immer der Meinung, dass er jetzt eine Quelle, eine Audioquelle haben muss. Und wenn die nicht mehr da ist, wie zum Beispiel ein Bluetooth-Telefon, was nicht mehr in Reichweite ist. Dann sind da sich halt irgendwas andert. Was ich jetzt gemacht habe, oder was ich gemacht hatte letztes Jahr, ich brauchte den USB-Port für so andere Kabel. Ich hab dann halt einfach so einen billigen USB-Stock von 1874 genommen, hab dann da so einen 10-Stunden-MP3 mit Silence drauf gemacht und das Ding da reingesteckt. Aber ich brauchte, wie gesagt, den Port noch für was anderes. Das kann auch echt nicht die Lösung sein. Und da würd ich auch gerne mal wissen von den Hörern. Ich hatte ja ein ähnliches Phänomen, aber nicht ganz so krass auch mit dem BMW vorher. Es scheint so zu sein, dass wenn du einen virtuellen Lautsprecher oder ein Bluetooth-Lautsprecher, das Auto ist ja ein Bluetooth-Lautsprecher für mein Telefon, wenn du das koppelst, dass beim Koppeln implizit ein Play mit dabei ist. Das heißt, wenn dein iPhone auf Pause steht und du koppelst es mit einem Lautsprecher denkt es sich, oh, ein Lautsprecher koppelt, bestimmt will was spielen, mach ich jetzt Play. Ich weiß aber noch nicht, wessen Schuld das ist. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob das sozusagen ein Apple-Problem ist oder ob das ein Thema ist, dass die Geräte das selber machen. Lautsprecher oder Bluetooth, da gibt es ja bestimmte Blutprofile.
Das hab ich aber auch gehabt.
Dass die einfach anfangen, Lust zu daddeln. Er sucht sich halt irgendein anderes Telefon, was da eingebucht ist, und dann koppelt sich mit dem, was ja auch okay ist, und dann erst mal so, ah, Play! Und fängt dann an irgendwelche Dinge. Das iPhone ist ja auch besonders krass. Wenn deine Podcast-App noch irgendwie einigermaßen vorne ist oder noch mal nichts raus im Speicher geschmissen wurde, das kann Roddi bestimmt am besten sagen, wie das geht mit diesen Prozessen, dann spielt er halt da weiter. Wenn der Telefon jetzt zu lange nicht in diesem Podcast-Betrieb hat, dann werden ja diese Prozesse zerschossen. Und dann bleibt halt bei denen Apple Music oder diese Drecks-Music ab. Wirklich die allerletzte ab. Dann bleibt die halt vorne und da spielt er halt eben irgendeinen Song. Meistens den ersten aus der Play.
Bei mir war das lange A-Bar.
Ja, oder egal. Und das finde ich so total innervierend. Du steigst in dieses Auto ein und es muss immer irgendeinen Krach machen. Ich würde gerne mal sagen, selectiere mal aus. Und dann bleib auch dabei, bis ich dir wieder sage, mach mal wieder an.
Also ich hab ein viel merkwürdigeres Problem. Also das hab ich auch gemerkt. Ich hab halt das Telefonnummer mit Kabel verbunden. Und irgendwie fährt er dann so halb Bluetooth über das Kabel oder ich weiß nicht genau, was die da fahren. Und dann fängt er auch an zu spielen. Aber ich hab auch ein ganz merkwürdiges Phänomen gehabt, dass ich, wenn ich die TomTom App gestartet hab, dann hat die keinen Sound gemacht, wenn ich nicht im Hintergrund Musik oder aber Podcast angemacht hab.
Das ist ja noch eine ganz andere Nummer. Der hat mir keine Directions gegeben. Nee, da hab ich so ein bisschen mehr hintergeguckt, was da passiert. Es gibt ja mehrere Art und Weise, wie so ein Gerät Sound abspielen kann. Nämlich einmal so wirklich im Hi-Fi-Modus, oder mit Stereo und so und scharf und so. Sozusagen für Remote-Lautsprecher. Und einmal im Telefonie-Modus. Und zum Beispiel, wenn du mit Google Maps machst, den als Navi benutzt, was ich tue, unter anderem, da kann man irgendwo einstellen, ob er dich jetzt anrufen soll. Was ganz lustig ist, dann kriegst du mal einen Anruf von deiner eigenen Nummer. Deine eigene Nummer im Display. Als wenn du so einen Anruf kriegst, der wird auch automatisch angenommen. Und dann kriegst du halt deine Navigationsansagen wieder gut. Und dadurch, dass das aber dieses Telefonprofil ist, hast du diese 3,1 Kilohertz gequaket. Also, und wenn du aber jetzt eh gerade Audio spielst, weil du jetzt einen Podcast oder so was am Gehen hast, oder meinetwegen Musik spielst, dann ist er sozusagen in diesem Hi-Fi-Bluetooth-Profil oder wie auch immer. Also in dem normalen Lautsprechermodus. Und dann quakt die Google-Tante da dazwischen. Und das hört sich dann auch wieder gut an. Wenn du jetzt nur einen von diesen Modi kannst, wenn deine Tom-Tom-Up jetzt nicht darauf Rücksicht nimmt, wie gerade die Bluetooth-Audiosituation ist, dann wird sie dich wahrscheinlich auch anrufen. Oder eben nur diesen Lautsprechermodus machen. Oder nur eins von beiden. Deswegen sag, wenn du was anderes spielst, dann hast du eh schon diese Audio-Connection zwischen dem Bluetooth-Lautsprecher und dem 5-stelligen Bluetooth-Lautsprecher, in dem du sitzt. Und dann kann sie halt mit quaken. Also das ist wirklich, dass da die Industrie noch nicht hintergekommen ist, wie man das richtig macht.
First-World-Problems.
Hast du keine Freisprechanrichtung?
Ich hab auf jeden Fall eine Menge First-World-Problems.
So ist es nicht. Du bist ja auch der Audiospezialist der Residente.
Dass das Telefon selber beim Connecten mit einem Bluetooth-Device sich selber playt, glaube ich nicht, das ist auf jeden Fall das Auto. Und hier schreibt auch gerade jemand, der BMW. BMW hat dasselbe Problem. Das scheint so typisch. Autohersteller, die alles besser wissen.
Ich glaube aber, wenn ich meinen...
Seit es Bluetooth gibt, haben Autohersteller alles missverstanden. Am Anfang die ersten Teile, ich weiß noch...
Aber Tesla ist kein Autohersteller. Tesla ist eine Computerbude, die jetzt Computer mit vier Rädern dran macht. Da würden wir jetzt meinen, dass sie besser drauf hätten. Aber nein.
Sehr lustig. Bei den ersten Devices, wo sie Bluetooth reingebaut haben, haben sie sich ja von Microsoft irgendwie helfen lassen. Also da kamen dann beides zusammen, Computerhersteller. Du kannst dir vorstellen, was passiert ist, wenn du mit Bluetooth koppelst. Was macht das Teil natürlich als erstes?
Es kopiert deine kompletten Kontakte ins Auto. Es kann ja sein, dass du mal jemanden anrufen musst.
In den Mietwagen! Solche Sachen kannst du im Tesla eigentlich nicht.
Das macht die Zoe übrigens auch.
Ja, das kann ich aber Tesla ansagen, ob er das tun soll oder nicht.
Gott, Leute, ich gleich. Diese ganzen Smart, das ist eigentlich das Problem. Elektroauto ist alles super, aber dieses Smart-Auto-Gedöns, da kommen Leute an, die nicht smart sind und tun dann, als wir ihr Gerät smart, und dann will das irgendwie mit meiner Infrastruktur interfacen, das kann doch nichts werden. Also ich bin ein bisschen abgetörnt irgendwie von Elektroauto. Ich glaube, ich überlege mir das nochmal.
Das hat jetzt aber nichts mit Elektroauto zu tun.
Nee, aber es ist halt alles automatisch versucht, alles so furchtbar smart zu sein. Vielleicht sind neue normale Autos auch smart.
Aber die bauen doch den gleichen Krempel auch in die Benziner ein.
Ja, aber ich habe ja noch mein altes Auto.
Hier schreibt gerade einer im Chat, dass er eine Bluetooth-Kassette hat.
Bluetooth-Kassette?
Das heißt, du musst jetzt überhaupt erst mal ein Autoradio haben, was noch so ein Kassettenschutz hat.
Bluetooth-Kassettenadapter, das ist super! Das ist besser als die Kassettenadapter mit Klinken, die wir früher hatten.
Ja, aber ein Quell steht da Freude, dieses Thema.
Nö, aber ansonsten ist die Zoe schon ein gutes Auto. Es fährt sich verdammt gut. Ich bin jetzt gestern wieder mal ein i3 gefahren und hatte das Gefühl, so aggressiv muss eigentlich der Gashebel gar nicht sein. Könnte eigentlich auch einfach ein bisschen softer fahren, das Auto. Wäre man eigentlich auch ganz gut unterwegs.
Was mich ja bei BMWs generell stört, ist so diese Myriade an Buttons, die sie da unterbringt.
Das ist aber bei einem i3, finde ich, nicht so schlimm.
Bei einem i3 haben sie es dann noch schlimmer gemacht. Was macht ein Autohersteller, wenn er etwas vereinfachen will, weil er vorher zu viele Buttons hatte?
Menü?
Ja, stimmt.
Ach du meinst das?
Das Ding einer Mittelkonsole, ne?
Oh Gott, das ist wirklich das Schlimmste.
Vor allem, wenn du dann hier irgendwie mit ähm, scheiß BMW Drive Now fährst. So, steigst du erstmal ein, steigst mit vier Leuten ein, gerade meine Karre gemietet und was sollste als erstes machen?
Auf diesem großen Button und dem riesigen Display, was natürlich jegliche Aktion, H-Klein-Echo, sollst du erstmal deine PIN eingeben.
Ja, vor allem, du musstest so reinkurbeln.
Genau, da musstest du so drehen auf die Vier.
Kommt mir vor wie mit einem Wählscheiben-Telefon. Wer denkt sich so ein Scheiß aus? Mein Gott, wenn er Buttons sparen wollt, da gibt's echt genug, aber wenn da irgendwie in so einem blöden Drive Now-Mietwagen regelmäßig PINs eingegeben werden sollen, wie wär's einfach mit einem Numpad? Also, da fang ich dann sofort an, dran zu zweifeln.
Du musst mal versuchen...
Ich hab auch wenig Hoffnung mit diesen großen Displays.
Du musst mal versuchen, das Navi mit dem Drehrad zu verwenden. Das ist erst richtig lustig, wenn du mit dem Wählscheibentelefon da Buchstaben eingeben darfst.
Dann ist auch alles so furchtbar zweideutig und mehrdeutig. Und dann musst du irgendwie alles noch einloggen und ausloggen und umschalten. Und wollen sie die Miete jetzt wirklich beenden? Ja, nein. Und drehst und nochmal und Menü und Exit und OK.
Aber das mach ich eigentlich nicht mehr über die App. Das geht eigentlich relativ gut. Du machst das Auto zu, das ist nie verboten.
Ja, stimmt, das hat sich verbessert. Das war am Anfang halt auch so was.
Wann braucht das?
Nee, genau, dann fragt er dich, Entschuldigung, das hab ich verwechselt, dann fragt er dich am Anfang, ob du noch irgendein blödes Zusatzpaket noch mieten möchtest. Versicherungsscheiß für jede Fahrt.
Das hab ich aber noch nie gehabt.
Doch, das hab ich immer bei Dreyf noch.
Echt? Sicher, dass das nicht Car2go ist?
Ja, deswegen benutze ich Car2go, weil der einfach weniger nervt. Ich fahr immer mit dem Miet, die am wenigsten nerven, deswegen fand ich vorher die Elektro-Karren von Multicity am besten, weil die haben einfach mal null genervt. Car2go hat das jetzt endlich auch sein lassen, mit diesen ganzen Pin-Gedöns und so weiter, weil das ist einfach mal unsinnig. Ich authentifiziere mich mit meiner fucking Karte und meinem Telefon jetzt sogar in der Regel. Da muss ich jetzt nicht noch Pins eingeben.
Ich mach das immer mit dem Telefon, also das geht eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, mittlerweile ist das ja auch so, aber das läuft ja auch schon seit ein paar Jahren. Am Anfang musstest du halt auch blöde Pins eingeben bei Car2go. Während du beim Multi City einfach aufmachen mit der App, oder ne, mit der Karte, Entschuldigung, mit der Karte, Schlüssel raus, reinstecken, losfahren und elektrisch und sofort nichts irgendwie eingeben, keine blöden Dialoge, kein Gerät, was mit dir sprechen möchte.
Spurensicherung.
Ich werd ja auch...
Wie lang gibt's diesen Siri-Scheißdreck jetzt schon?
Keine Ahnung, zu lang.
Fünf Jahre?
Vier Jahre?
Wie lange gibt's das? Schreibt mir mal, wie lange es Siri gibt.
Ich glaube, iPhone 4S. Für iPhone 3S, 3GS.
Nee, da gab's noch kein Siri.
Doch, ich glaube, da war das das erste Mal die Hardware für drin.
Also, ich hör jetzt auch 4S klingt. Genau, hier der Chat sagt 4S. Genau, 4S klingt sinnvoll. Weil das hatte ich nicht und hab ich nichts vermisst. Und dann, ganz ehrlich, fangen wir nochmal an, 4S, das heißt, 4S, 5, 5S, 6, 6, 6S, 7, 7, 8, 8X.
4S, 5, 5S, 6, 6, 6S, 7, 7, 8, 8X.
8 und X. Ja, also 7 Jahre. Wahnsinn.
Seit 7 Jahren gibt's das?
Ja, und es tut immer noch nicht.
Es ist nichts, es ist nichts, es ist, es ist, es ist ein... Benutzst du das? Ich benutze es...
Clemens, benutzt du Siri?
Ich benutze das manchmal, wenn ich irgendwie irgendwo in fremder Umgebung mitten in der Nacht liege und mit Jetlag oder so, dann frage ich Siri mal, wie spät es ist. So, weil das kriegst du ganz gut geregelt, mit der lokalen Zeitzone und dem ganzen Zeug. So nach dem Motto, ey Siri, wo bin ich und wie spät ist es? Aber abgesehen davon benutz ich sie beim Autofahren zum Anwählen von Leuten. Weil ich ja ein bewusster Autofahrer bin und nicht rumdaddel auf dem Telefon. Siri, ruf mal Tim an, mobil und so. Das konnte auch mein Auto früher. Ohne Siri.
Wo du mir gerade erzählst, was du mit Siri machst, fällt mir gerade wieder eine meiner Lieblingsstellen aus dem Parallel durch die Galaxis ein. Wo ja Marvin, auch eine hoch ausgeprägte Intelligenz, sich darüber beklagt, wie Leute immer mit ihm umgehen.
Hier stehe der Gehirn von der Größe eines Planeten.
Und was sagt man zu mir? Öffne Schleuser Nummer 4, Marvin. Ja, das sind Dinge, die man zu mir sagt. Und in diesem Universum liegt Siri auf unserem Planeten, könnte uns alle Fragen beantworten, aber man fragt sie die ganze Zeit nur, wie spät es ist.
Na, jetzt zu den meisten anderen Sachen hat Siri ja keine Antwort.
Wie komme ich jetzt eigentlich auf Siri? Ah ja, genau, ich mag es nicht, wenn Computer mit mir reden. Und ich habe schon ehrlich gesagt, ganz ehrlich, seit Jahren frage ich mich, ob ich jetzt alt, senil werde und irgendwie das Licht nicht mehr sehe. Kann ja sein.
Na, welches Licht? Also...
Na, das Licht von der Zukunft. Was ich in anderen Bereichen durchaus gesehen habe, da gab es so Entwicklungen, da dachte ich mir so, hm, das ist bestimmt geil, das wird bestimmt mal richtig cool. Und das wurde dann vielleicht auch, oder auch mal nicht. Aber ich hatte so zumindest so eine Phase von 20 Jahren, wo ich sagen würde, da bin ich jetzt so an den meisten Trends nicht so dran vorbeigeschlittert und wenn, dann absichtlich, weil es mich einfach persönlich nicht interessiert.
Weil du jetzt gerade Douglas Adams zitiert hast, kennst du, was er da gesagt hat. Das ist sozusagen Technologie, die zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du geboren bist, da sind, ist Gott gegeben.
Genau.
Bis du 30 bist, oder irgendwann 30, glaube ich, noch hinzukommt, nimmst du noch mit auf und kommst dann mit nach, und danach ist wieder die Natur.
Und da habe ich natürlich auch berechtigte Angst davor, dass ich irgendwann mal da in diese Reihen fahre. Und dachte immer so, mit diesem Computerredending, das ist jetzt so mein wieder die Natur-Ding.
Mir fällt jetzt sowieso schon schwer, mit Geräten zu reden, die ich nicht an meinen Ohr halte. Mich irritierte total, wenn Leute auf der Straße rumlaufen, ist jetzt total hip-hoppig festgestellt, Leute auf der Straße rumlaufen, sich das Handy so einen halben Meter vor die Schnauze halten und entweder eben mit Freisprechanrechnungen telefonieren und dann übrigens noch meistens in die falsche Seite vom Gerät reinquaken. Also die quaken dann so oben rein. Aber ok, schön, wir haben ja heute überall Mikrofone an den Dingern oben und unten. Aber was jetzt auch der totale heiße Scheiße ist, ist WhatsApp, was ich ja eh schon überhaupt nicht abkann, aber dann WhatsApp-Voice-Nachrichten schicken. Sie stehen da mit dem Ding, so ein Handy, halten sich so mit ein bisschen Abstand vor die Schnauze und drücken da diesen scheiße Voice-Message. Und dann laufen sie wieder drei Meter und dann quaken, dann macht das Ding wieder pingen und dann drücken sie wieder drauf und dann hören sie sich mit Lautsprechern. Nicht, dass man sich das Ding als Ohr halten würde, sondern mit Lautsprecher hören sie sich den anderen, was die Gegenseite zurückgequakt hat.
Wie will er damals?
Da hat es so einen Hörer am Ohr.
Das irritiert mich doch zusehends. Aber das schreib ich jetzt einfach mal an meine Hand.
Ja, aber worauf ich hinaus wollte ist, obwohl ich die ganze Zeit diesen Verdacht habe, dass das unter Umständen etwas ist, was ich vollkommen verkenne, sehe ich irgendwie immer noch nicht, dass der Scheiß irgendwie überzeugend funktioniert. Also vielleicht gibt es mal wieder so einen Tag, wo alles umkippt und auf einmal ist es Montag und alles ist anders. Aber es funktioniert nicht. Ich will es nicht. Es wird mir die ganze Zeit nahegelegt, das wäre eine tolle Entwicklung. Seit sieben Jahren arbeiten sie daran. Nichts kommt dabei raus.
Also meinen letzten brauchbaren Siri-Moment hatte ich ja, als ich das iPhone X neu hatte und es nicht ausgeschaltet bekommen hab.
Du hast gesagt, Siri-Schalter schalte ich ab?
Nee, da hab ich gesagt, Siri, wie schalte ich das Telefon aus? Und dann hat sie es mir erklärt. Okay, das nächste wollte ich deine App beenden. Und dann frage ich Siri, warte mal, ich muss jetzt schnell diesen Screenshot finden, weil der ist einfach zu großartig. Dann wollte ich von Siri wissen, wie man das Telefon, wie man da eine App beendet. Und dann sagte sie so sinngemäß, du hast keine App, die heißt, wie beende ich eine oder so ähnlich. Wie beende ich eine App? Und Siri sagt, du scheinst keine App mit dem Namen, wie beende ich eine zu haben. Wenn du möchtest, kann ich im App Store danach suchen. Und da ist dann auch meine Lust, Siri weiter zu benutzen, auch direkt am Ende.
Nur ist das aber auch so, dass...
Warte mal, wie nennt man das? Das ist so Uncanny Valley-mäßig.
Jenseits von. Also das ist noch nicht anerkennend.
Das sind so diese Momente, wo du so... Warte mal, da gibt es da irgendwelche Filme, wo du glaubst, ist das jetzt ein Roboter oder ist das so ein richtiges Wesen? Und dann verraten sie sich durch eine vollkommen trottelige Fehler. Weißt du, durch eine vollkommen bekloppte Antwort. Und so ähnlich ist das so ein bisschen. Stell dir vor, triffst sowieso Siri, hübsche junge Frau, steht so auf der Straße und du fragst sie, oder sagen sie mir doch mal, wie ich zum Bahnhof komme. Und sie sagt so, ja hier, ich kann ihnen erläutern, wie sie zum Bahnhof kommen und so. Und dann sagst du am Schluss irgendwie danke und dann, ich konnte diese App nicht finden. Und schau dich irgendwie so an mit so einem leicht leeren Blick und weißt so, oh Gott.
Die User sind aber auch doof. Welche User? Alle. Aber was ich zuerst sagen wollte, ich hatte eine ähnliche Diskussion neulich mal beim Mittagessen mit Projektkollegen, die alle so, keine Ahnung, 25, 25 Jahre jünger sind. Und die meinten alle, ja, ja, Siri ist so sehr großer Scheiß. Aber mehrere von denen schworen auf Alexa. Sie meinen, das sei Lichtjahre entfernt von dem, was Siri und auch die sind Google. Die gibt ja auch dieses OK Google. Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt. Aber dieses Alexa-Ding, sind auch wirklich Leute, die sich solche Geräte zu Hause hinstellen. Natürlich in jedem Raum eine, weil die sind auch weit ab jeder Privacy-Konzern oder sonst irgendwas. Die findet halt einfach toll und die quatschen halt einfach so, nicht dass sie sich vorher einen Satz überlegen, sondern die quatschen einfach so rein so Alexa, brauche ich nachher einen Regenschirm oder sowas. Diese üblichen Demo-Geschichten. Das sollte wohl, angeblich sollte das ganz gut funktionieren. Mehrere Leute meinten, das sei ganz geil und Siri sei ein totaler Scheißdreck dagegen. Und sie werden halt ganz verwundert, weil es gibt halt Riesenfirmen, die sich da dran befummeln. Okay, Google, den soll es zwar auch besser sein als Siri, aber auch nicht viel. Die wahnsinnig viel Geld da reinschmeißen, seit Jahren daran forschen. Und dieses Alexa-Zug ist ja noch verhältnismäßig neu, also in diesem Spiel. Und haben sich denn darüber gewundert, wie halt eben so ein Newcomer wie Amazon eben da hingehen kann und da gleich mal so eine gute Leistung abliefern kann. Aber ich hab selber so ein Ding nicht, würde es mir auch nie hin tun, aus religiösen Gründen nicht. Aber vielleicht kann der Chat mal sagen, wie sie Alexa finden.
Eine Alexa hat ja ein sehr einfach gestricktes Vokabular. Also es ist mehr so Command Line Interface gesprochenes als...
Na wenn du so Skills machst schon.
Du hast da schon so gewisse Patterns, denen du da quasi mit deinen Befehlen folgst. Damit kommt man bloß relativ weit. Das macht aber natürlich die Kontextualisierung deiner Aussage natürlich sehr viel einfacher. Und deswegen performen sie da auch so gut. Das ist an sich ein ganz kluger Schachzug. Sie haben sich einfach entschlossen, erstmal nicht so viel mit Intelligenz zu machen, sondern einfach mit so einem einfachen Anpassungs-Set, wo sich quasi der User, der Maschine nicht zu weit runterbeugen muss, aber durch ein gewisses Entgegenkommen eine sehr hohe Kompatibilität herstellen kann. Während Siri von vornherein, und bei Google weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, wie sie das angelegt sind, aber die sind ja eigentlich auch so AI-mäßig unterwegs, die wollen halt eigentlich total kontextualisieren und da irgendwie Werben und Objekte und so weiter mit reinbringen, sodass du dann eben auch sehr viel mehr Spielraum hast. Oder du kannst da so komplexe Objekte beschreiben und dein Programm kann das dann irgendwie...
Das ist von jedem Problem, das ich habe. Das kann Siri überhaupt nicht. Gebt dafür eine ab oder nicht?
Ja, Siri macht das ja eher so Domänen. Also wir haben ja jetzt immer wieder so neue Domänen von Apps, die sie jetzt unterstützen. Da haben sie dann irgendwie so Messenger-Apps. Das sind so drei, vier, fünf Domänen, die sie unterstützen. Ich verfolge das auch nur so ein bisschen genauso mit einem Auge. Und dann können sie eben Programmen, die in dieser Domäne unterwegs sind, in ein relativ komplexes Vermittlungsset weiterleiten. Ob das der richtige Weg ist?
Da gibt es den Begriff der Happy Eyeballs, den Begriff der Happy Eardrums, dass das einfach mal funktioniert. Sie können es ja immer noch schlauer machen.
Es sind zwei unterschiedliche Ansätze. Irgendwie muss Siri da noch einen gewissen Durchbruch erreichen, den sie immer noch nicht erreicht haben und von dem vielleicht auch keiner weiß, ob sie ihn jemals erreichen werden.
Obwohl vor einer Weile habe ich den Timer auch ganz gerne verwendet, so auf der Uhr. Also machst du das Siri auf der Uhr ansatz, Timer drei Minuten, dann denkt irgendwie, da musst du vorher schon wissen, dass Siri deine 15 Sekunden drüber nachdenkt und dir dann entweder sagt, das habe ich nicht verstanden oder ja ist okay, hier ist dein Timer.
Timer, ich drücke irgendwie rechts auf meine große Tasse, wähle Timer aus, wähle die Zeit aus.
Ja, wenn du, weiß ich nicht, wenn du beim Abwaschen bist und nasse Hände hast und so weiter, dann ist es einfacher irgendwie halt so.
Es wäre einfacher, aber ich meine ein Timer, wo ich dann irgendwie nach 15 Sekunden die Informationen bekomme, ob vor 15 Sekunden er mich überhaupt verstanden hat, was ich ihm gesagt habe, ist keine Hilfe.
Naja, man hat das Gefühl, er nimmt das erst auf der Uhr ab.
Das ist so wie Siri, kannst du mal die Leiter festhalten?
Soll ich nach, für dich nach Leitern im Internet zu handeln?
Was mir noch anekdotisch einfällt zu dem Thema User sind doof und du meintest so die Virtualisierer, die dir auf der Straße begegnen, der du dann dankst für ihren Weg oder so, ja. Ich war auch an einem Projekt beteiligt Anfang des Jahrtausends. Also Pré-Smartphone. Dort gab es in Deutschland einen Mobilfunkprovider, der sich dachte, das wäre eine super tolle Idee, wenn wir jedem Kunden eine E-Mail-Adresse geben. Und das war ein Mobilfunkprovider. Das heißt, du hast als E-Mail-Adresse, wenn du dich dafür entschieden hast, deine Telefonnummer, add domain, gekriegt. Kann man auch sagen, D2-E-Mail war das. Was könnte möglicherweise falsch gehen? Das war jetzt erstmal okay. Nur, manche Leute finden es nicht so cool, ihre Telefonnummer drin zu haben. Deswegen gab es ein Feature, was auch hinreichend dokumentiert war, mit all diesen üblichen Dingern, die Vodafone damals so drauf hatte, mit ihren Info-Faxen. Er war ja nicht Vodafone, er war ja Mannesmann. Mit ihren Info-Faxen und tralala und da noch eine Webseite und hier noch eine Beschreibung. Wie gesagt, das war so um die 2000 rum. Dass du deinen Namen ändern kannst, steht drauf. Schicken sie einfach eine SMS mit ihrem, oder kurzmitteilung, schicken sie eine kurzmitteilung mit dem gewünschten E-Mail-Namen an folgende Kurzrufnummer. Und da ist halt so ein Server von uns dahinter. Und die Idee war, dass du sozusagen, wenn du jetzt Tim Prittlauf haben willst, einfach tim.prittlauf an diese Nummer geschickt und das System hat dann zurückgeantwortet, ja, wir haben jetzt ihre E-Mail-Adresse unbedannt von 4917, schieß mich tot, auf tim.prittlauf.de So weit, so gut. Die Leute haben nicht verstanden, dass das ein Computersystem ist, was das ist. Das heißt, die haben, nachdem sie diese Nachricht gekriegt haben, haben sie darauf mit Danke geantwortet. Daraufhin hat das System gesagt, herzlichen Glückwunsch, wir haben jetzt ihre E-Mail-Adresse geändert von tim.prittlauf.de d2eemail.de auf danke.de d2eemail.de Wir haben Wochen damit zugebracht, Sperrlisten zu pflegen. Wir hatten natürlich eh schon Sperrlisten drin, wo halt so die üblichen Spacken drauf sind. Also so SS, Hitler, Lalalala und so, Arschloch und so weiter und so fort. Was die da nicht so lustig fanden, hat eh schon so eine White List und wir haben wirklich Wochen damit zugebracht, um zu gucken, was die User da alle reinschreiben. Obwohl ihnen tausendmal, wir haben ja auch die initiale Message geändert, bitte antworten sie nicht auf diese Nachricht, weil die wird von einem Rechner, sie haben trotzdem so Danke, Dankeschön oder so andere Fragen gestellt. Und das Beste war, der Top-Hit in dieser Liste war, hiermit kündige ich mein Konto bei der Postbank Karlsruhe. Als Nachricht in dieses System rein. Und du denkst, genau, du denkst so, what? Danke. Du guckst jetzt, ob die Falcon aus dem Kniff kommt, oder was?
Genau.
Das ist ja mal ganz schön, wenn du dir das mal anguckst.
Ach, so eine Falcon?
Du hast ja schon ein paar von diesen Dingern gesehen. Die haben unten immer so ihre Zeitlinie, so mit diesen Punkten, was so was passiert, wann so ihre einzelnen Stufen absprengen und wenn die daheim fliegen und so. Das machen die schon ganz gut. Vielleicht verlieren sie irgendwann auch mal die Lust da dran. Aber wir haben immer so zwei junge Moderatoren, Männchen, Weibchen da rumhopsen, die das dann erklären und so. Und haben die Spaß dran. Public Relations bei SpaceX.
Ja, ist alles amerikanisch aber gut gemacht. Also im Vergleich zu den doch verhältnismäßig trockenen Sachen, wie sie bei ESA da laufen. Vor allem halt so mit Live-Bildern von der Rakete. Das ist halt einfach mal cool.
Das hast du halt bei der ESA nicht. Vor allem kann auch nicht wahnsinnig viel kosten dazu bauen. Machen die Russen sowas eigentlich? Kann man sich so Soyuz-Starts angucken live? Nee, gibt den Kasachstan nicht genug Internet dafür oder wie?
Du meinst jetzt von der Rakete oder an sich den Staat?
Na so, hier, dass man so live kickert, wurde so und dann vielleicht die...
Ja, die haben schon auch...
Arianis, Frix und so.
Das wär jetzt eigentlich noch...
Nein, du siehst...
Launches gibts immer im Internet zu sehen. Die Frage ist nur, siehst du Bilder von der Rakete durchgehend, während sie durchs Weltall fliegt? Und das macht halt eigentlich so, meines Wissens, nur...
Also so einen richtigen Live-Feed.
So einen richtigen Live-Feed mit zack jetzt hier die Booster abgesprengt und Pipapo.
Lustig sind ja immer die Dinger, wenn sie wieder landen, wenn die ihre Füßchen ausklappen und so.
Ja, ich mein, das war natürlich der Oberbrüller, muss man echt mal sagen. Also da haben sie schon was geleistet.
Und geht auch schnell, ne? Man würde jetzt immer so denken, oh, dann landet die und dann gibt es irgendjemand einen Kommando und dann fahren sie ihr Triebwerk runter oder wie so, ne, das macht halt so... Lichtausfertig so. Ende. Ja.
Ja, stimmt, das geht verdammt schnell. Vor allen Dingen auch dieses ok, jetzt Booster Separation, dann dreht das Ding um, feuert mal, fällt wieder zurück und stellt sich da einfach freut. Ja, der Hof stellt sich hin. Flamme aus, Kerze aus, fertig. Ja, das wär's jetzt eigentlich auch noch. So eine Anomaly bei der Falcon, so als Höhepunkt in der Sendung.
Ach, ich weiß nicht.
Wann geht denn das da los?
Auch die Leute in Europa da, also...
Ja, nein, man wünscht natürlich niemandem einen schönen Start.
Nee, das glaub ich denen auch. Das sagen die nämlich auch alle. Also keiner wünscht sich im Weltraum Stress bei den anderen.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Weil die alle viel zu sehr voneinander abhängen. Und ich meine, es ist ja ordentlich nicht so, dass diese ganze SpaceX-Geschichte so komplett daneben läuft. Was ist das jetzt? Das zeigen sie.
Achso, das ist irgendeine Preview?
Haben sie die Erdkugel verschmiert?
Ja, das haben sie ja bunte Bilder. Das würde wahrscheinlich alles Sinn machen, wenn ich den Ton anmache, aber das mache ich jetzt mal nicht.
Wann geht es los? Vier Minuten.
Ich frage mich nur, was so ein GovSat ist. Geostationary Transfer Orbit.
Military K-Band. Naja, was so ein Government halt mit so einem Satellit so macht.
Will not attempt to recover Falcon 9 first stage. Also ohne... Das habe ich übrigens nie so ganz verstanden. Wofür hängt das eigentlich ab?
Sie brauchen Sprit, um das Ding wieder landen zu können.
Achso, mit GTO reicht es nicht.
Manchmal ballern sie die Dinger so hoch oder so weit weg, dass sie nicht mehr genug Sprit haben, um mit dem Ding landen zu können.
Ja, beim geostationären Orbit ist dann einfach zu viel.
Kostet halt entsprechend mehr, ne?
So viel passt vielleicht nicht rein.
Sie kommen wahrscheinlich auf den geostationären Orbit auch, aber du hast halt dann weniger Payload. Also sie kann halt mehr Payload, wenn du den Booster hinterher wegwirfst.
Ja, weil du den Sprit nicht brauchst, um das Ding zu landen.
Richtig.
Und das muss der Auftraggeber zahlen. Aber wenn der zahlt und sagt, uns ist das jetzt so und so viel Millimeter wert, dass wir da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, eine halbe Tonne mehr fliegen können, dann kriegen sie halt Booster.
Aber sie benutzen wohl Booster, die sie schon mal geflogen haben. Oder zweimal oder dreimal. Jetzt bei diesem Start. Wenn sie welche wegschmeißen, weil sie, wie gesagt, nicht nur Sprit haben, dann nehmen sie wohl welche, die sie schon mal geflogen haben.
Ich glaube, wenn du da als Auftraggeber sagst, ich will einen nagelneuen Booster und ihr sollt ihn wegschmeißen, dann steht die entsprechende Zahl auf dem Papier und wenn du das zahlst, dann machen sie es. Also...
Ich find's ja immer wieder interessant, das Thema hatten wir letztes Mal schon mal angerissen, dass die Europäer ja anders zählen als die Amerikaner beim Countdown.
Ja, als ich diese Zusammenschnitz da vorgestellt hatte von diesen wahnsinnigen Polen, der für 2016 und 2015 glaube ich war, sämtliche Raketenstaats in einem Video auf Vimeo zusammengeschnitten haben. Ah ja, richtig. Genau.
Also die Amerikaner, also die Europäer, machen Countdown... Also was würdest du erwarten, was bei Null passiert? War so gefragt.
Naja, dass man da mal das Haupttriebwerk mal... Die glühnet ja schon ein bisschen vor, aber dass man dann sozusagen, dass man da aufs Gaspedal tritt.
Also, was machen die Europäer?
Dass bei der Null gezündet wird. Meinst du das?
Das ist ja mal so ein Zündzeitpunkt, die haben ja mehrere Dinger, die so dann zünden und bei flüssiges Zeug...
Ja, aber was passiert bei der Null?
Was passiert bei der Null?
Ja, trittst du das Gaspedal durch.
Ja, was passiert dann? Also was sieht man?
Ja, Fett, Flamme und so. Und so steigt das Ding hoch. Wenn da genug Thrusts sich zusammen geben. Ja, aber wann?
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt?
Das ist Countdown.
Du bist Europäer.
Das ist die europäische Zielweise.
Die Amerikaner machen das halt anders. Das passt ganz gut zusammen. Die Amerikaner machen das halt auf Null. So, die zünden halt vorher. Und Null ist, wenn das Ding abhebt. Lift-off. Das heißt, die haben auf Null den Lift-off. Die Amerikaner, die Franzosen, haben bei Null Allumage. Das ist der Unterschied. Das heißt, der Nerd-Ansatz ist, jetzt zünden wir und die Amerikaner halt so voll Show-mäßig, Null ist halt. Lift-off!
Verstehe, wenn es sich bewegt.
Ab in die Sterne, wenn es sich bewegt.
Aber das beschleunigt ja, das heißt, es macht erst mal langsam Lift-off. Ist ja nicht so näher oder nicht.
Nein, die Raketen müssen ja erst mal anfangen richtig zu glühen. Aber das ist ja, was ich gerade sage, soll ich die letzte Minute noch einen Ton draufhauen?
Ne, ne, ne, warte mal. Vorher noch, wobei gerade andere Leute zählen anders. Jetzt muss ich auch mal aus meinem Bereich eine Quote reinwerfen.
Du hast nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Ihr erinnert euch noch daran, in so Wählscheiben-Telefone? Wie sahen denn die aus? Wo war denn da die Null?
Hinter der Neun.
Die war hinter der Neun, ja.
Ein Elfimpulse war zum kostenlos Telefonieren.
Ja, wer's glaubt.
Ich hab's gemacht?
Ja, es ging bis 15. 30? Egal. Es gab aber auch Länder, oder Länder gibt's immer noch, aber es gab so Telefonsysteme, da war die Null vor der Eins. Was immer ein großer Spaß war, wenn man diese Telefonnetze damals zusammenschaltete, zum Beispiel Russland. Ein russisches Wählscheiben-Telefon hat die Null vor der Eins.
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 0 . Da hat er aber schon bei...
Bei zwei Sekunden haben die gezündet. Und ab geht er, der Peter. Wow, ist ja schneller auf 100 als ein Tesla. Guck mal, wie das alles... Wie die Kamera da vibriert.
Wenn die so ein Ding...
Ich wollte das auch miterleben, fuck. Aber geht gut hoch.
Die Kamera geht deswegen, weil sie auch... Die hat ein tierisches Zoom, die steht ja nicht nebenan. Die hat ein tierisches Zoom und kriegt aber jetzt noch ein bisschen Krach auch noch um die Ohren.
Dieses Knackern, was man im Ton so hört, das ist wohl so angeblich, ist es so blöd. Der hat jetzt mich dahin gefahren und das Einzige, was ich erzählen kann, ist Hören sagen. Aber ich hab mit vielen Leuten da gesprochen. Unter anderem hatte ich auch noch einen angehenden ESA-Astronauten da noch mit im Gepäck. Der dann tatsächlich ganz nah dran war. Nämlich fünf Kilometer nur vom Startpunkt. Also das Kontrollzentrum ist zwölf. Also das Missionskontrollzentrum ist zwölf Kilometer entfernt. Das Raketen-Startkontrollzentrum ist näher dran. Ich weiß gerade nicht genau, aber wahrscheinlich auch fünf Kilometer. Weil fünf Kilometer ist der Sicherheitsabstand, den du erhalten musst.
Was das eigentliche Problem ist?
Schalldruck? Also Schall ist wohl auch ein Problem. Aber da kannst du ja ordentlichen Bukka bauen. Da kannst du Schutz aufsetzen. Das Problem ist, dass einfach durch den Start extrem viel Sauerstoff der Luft entzogen wird. Und wenn du da zu nah dran bist, dann gibt es halt einfach nichts zu atmen.
Meinst du, wenn die so ein Ding starten, dann wären die Viecher, die da in der Gegend sind, nicht nur gehörlos, sondern auch haben ein leichtes Atemschnappproblem oder so?
Auf jeden Fall. Also wenn man jetzt so einen Karnickel da unmittelbar rumlaupeln will, dann ist geröstet und ein paar Meter weiter ist vielleicht ein bisschen Sauerstoffarmut angesagt.
Die haben hier aber keine In-Flight-Streaming diesmal. Scheint ein ganz besonders wichtiger GovSat zu sein.
Vielleicht kommt das noch. Die haben ja so Phasen, wo sie dann fliegen, wo sie mit ihrer Konnektivität nicht so gut am Start sind. Da sind sie eher auf Edge.
Jetzt kommt auch Main Angel Cut-Off. Weil sind sie 60 Kilometer schon.
Ah, jetzt sieht man.
Da hast du. Da sieht man auch sehr schön, wie so...
Das ist immer ein schönes Bild. So abspringen plötzlich so die Erde.
Ist so angeblich flach.
Hat jemand eine Ecke rausgebissen, aber eigentlich ist die flach.
Er ist ja trotzdem rund am Rand. Ah, jetzt fängt es schön an zu flöten.
Was soll ich eigentlich gerade hinaus? Jetzt habe ich mich selber zweimal unterbrochen.
Gibt es da jetzt eigentlich noch mal ein Retry? Oder wartet jetzt? Wartet jetzt dein eine Ticket nach Kourou und Réane Vapu?
Da war jetzt erstmal nur ein Zettel am Los, aber ich gebe jetzt so schnell nie auf. Das fand ich jetzt ein bisschen fies von der Welt. Und gemein.
Warum habt ihr das eigentlich so kurzfristig gemacht? Aus Kosten oder sonstigen Gründen hätten die ja einen Tag früher hinfliegen, ausschlafen lassen können.
Ja, hätte Fahrradkette. Ich meine, solche Reisen erzeugen Kosten, die sie ja weitgehend getragen haben. Und einen ganzen Tag extra nochmal, hab ich ja für dich schon erzählt, oder 10 Tage Hotel, 10 Leute Hotel, tralala nochmal.
Ich denke, die haben da jede Menge Facilities für ihre eigenen Buben, die sie da rankarren aus ganz Europa und aus der ganzen Welt. Da haben die nicht mal irgendwie nochmal ein Bett für...
Die haben da kein Hotel auf dem Bahnhof.
Warum nicht? Die haben Dutzende von Europäern, die da...
Nein, niemand wohnt da. Niemand wohnt auf dem Compound. Das ist ausschließlich Arbeiten. Jeder fährt nach Hause. Es gibt da keine... Da ist vielleicht mal irgendwo eine Pritsche, keine Ahnung, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber es gibt da keine Wohneinheiten, es gibt da niemanden, der da wirklich lebt. Und es gibt auch keine Hotelbetten oder sowas. Das ist halt im Zweifelsfall auch alles ein Gebiet, was mal eben zack zack evakuiert werden muss.
Ja, evakuiert auch, aber jedes Forschungsinstitut hat irgendwie mal mehr als ein...
Forschungsinstitut startet aber auch keine Raketen. Das ist einfach so, egal.
Du meinst, die haben Angst, dass ihre Gäste verklagt werden wegen Geräusche, oder?
Es wird wohl bisher immer funktioniert haben. Und guckt ihr mal ein paar...
Guck dir mal ein paar fehlgeleitete Raketenstarts an. Da willst du dann auch nicht im 5-km-Radius sein.
Oder auch nur im 12-km-Radius.
12-km-Radius sind da schon... Wenn man da in Kourou wohnt, dann ist man schon im 15-km-Radius.
Am krassesten muss wohl das letzte große Fail von dieser russischen sowjetischen Mondrakete N1 gewesen sein. Da hat es laut Berichten noch eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten später...
Teile geregnet.
Teile geregnet und vor allen Dingen auch Treibstoff geregnet. Und dann willst du da nicht wohnen. Also das kann schon mal passieren.
Also ich...
Ich möchte das jetzt auf jeden Fall noch mal sehen. Ich möchte noch mal hin und ich möchte überhaupt gerne mehr Zeit haben. Das war jetzt zwar alles ganz aufregend und mal ganz interessanter Querschnitt, aber um das Ganze mal wirklich gut zu dokumentieren und schön zu beschreiben, müsste man da eigentlich noch mal ein bisschen mehr Zeit verbringen. Ich werd's probieren, aber das muss ich dann wahrscheinlich selber finanzieren. Das kann ein bisschen aufwendiger werden. Aber dann würde ich halt auch so mit... Weiß nicht, ich würde am liebsten mit so einem Trupp auftauchen. Also so richtig... Leute, die das mit den Kameras richtig können und so weiter.
Sendereinsatzkommando. Ja, vielleicht auch.
Drohnenoperator. Einfach so voll Monty. Wird dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwierig mit Security Clearance und so, aber man kann es ja zumindest mal probieren. Aber das wär auf jeden Fall ganz sinnvoll, das mal so richtig schön durchzuschlöbern. Na ja, haben sich ja auf jeden Fall ein paar interessante Kontakte draus ergeben und ich denke mal, das wird dann mittelfristig auch Raumzeit beleben. So, was ich jetzt noch dann verkünden muss, ich hab da noch eine Anschaffung gemacht, weil ich ja mit dem ganzen 360 Grad, Klempe und so weiter, da merkte ich auf einmal, oh weia, ich brauch jetzt irgendwie mal ein bisschen mehr. Also ich bin jetzt auf einmal sehr viel visueller unterwegs, als ich das normalerweise bin. Ich bin ja eigentlich nicht so ein Kamera- und Videomensch. Mir geht das eigentlich immer so ziemlich an allem vorbei. Aber jetzt wollte ich halt mal so mit diesem ganzen 360 Grad Kamerakram rum experimentieren. Da hab ich ja letztes Mal ja auch erzählt, dass ich diese GoPro Fusion dabei hatte, die lustigerweise, glaub ich, zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir darüber geredet haben, noch gar nicht so richtig im Verkauf war. Oder dann doch, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau. Jetzt ist die auf jeden Fall irgendwie erst so richtig released. Aber die ganze, die Software ist jetzt auch irgendwie auch erst so richtig dafür erschienen. Furchtbare Software, grauenhaft. Ich weiß nicht, was die sich alle dabei denken. Wie die sich das so vorstellen.
Bietet nicht immer mit solchen Gadgets. Da wird halt eine tolle Firma beschäftigt, was hinzuwechseln zu einem Zeitpunkt X, was dann halt gerade so noch funktioniert. Und dann ist gut. Und dann gibt's ja schon das nächste Modell. Warum soll man das noch in Ordnung bringen?
Das ist doch ein klassisches Thema. Ich kann nur hoffen, dass sie da noch viel Energie reinstecken, weil so ist es eher ein bisschen grenzwertig. Aber geht gerade noch so. Aber unabhängig von der Kamera, ich dachte mir halt so, du brauchst jetzt doch mal ein Device mit einem größeren Screen. Weil du ja so ein kleines Telefon, die Paar war eigentlich immer bin und war. Und nachher natürlich braucht die auch mehr Platz. Also ich war schon von so einem 256 GB Storage durchaus angesprochen. Und dann habe ich mich halt entschlossen, doch ein X-Zug rufen. Was ich dann getan habe.
Wie ist jetzt die offizielle Sprachregelung, für die man nicht erschossen wird? X oder X?
In Deutschland sagt man X. Das ist doch schon, vor wie vielen Jahren mit Mac OS.
Ja, ich finde den Namen immer noch scheiße. Und das hilft keinem so richtig weiter. Ich denke, in Deutschland sagen alle X. Und wenn du es international darüber kommunizierst, heißt es irgendwie 10 oder was auch immer.
Kannst auch 10 nennen, wenn du willst.
Ihr wisst schon, das Ding ohne Homebunten ist jetzt nicht wirklich brandneu. Du hast ja 1, Huckel an 1, Dennis hat 1.
Ja, mal abgesehen davon, dass diese Gesichtserkennung könnte noch besser sein, finde ich. Und was ich auch eine Weile lang, bis ich gefunden habe, wo man es ausschaltet, was mich tierisch genervt hat, war längeres Drücken auf diesen Seitenschalter. Macht irgendwie den Dings an, diese Sprachsteuerung. Nee, nicht beide gleichzeitig, sondern nur den großen Seitenschalter. Macht was an? Dieses Voice-Over. Mir ist es immer wieder passiert, dass ich Voice-Over angemacht habe, aus Versehen.
Diese behinderten Funktionen.
Und ich hab's dann ausgeschaltet bekommen in dem Dings.
Dem Siri gefragt hast?
Nein, ich hab selber in den Settings geguckt und hab's dann ausgeschaltet. Seitdem bin ich ein bisschen zufriedener.
Ich kann da nach wie vor nicht mitreden. Ich hatte das ja noch immer gesagt, ich bin immer noch mit meinem 6S und das wird auch wahrscheinlich mein letztes iPhone sein. Wenn das kaputt geht, dann hör ich einfach auf damit. Genauso wie mit meinen Rechnern.
Und wieso telefonierst du dann nicht mehr oder was?
Keine Ahnung. Guck ich mir wieder so ein Nokia-Dumpatzen-Ding oder den Nachfolger von meinem Nexus, finde ich eigentlich ganz okay. Aber momentan hab ich gerade so ein bisschen die Backen voll von dem Apple-Zeug.
Warum?
Wir sind way beyond peak Apple. Das ist alles kaputt, geht nicht mehr, Scheiße, teuer, machen Akkuspielchen, also das nervt mich. Das sind lauter Kleinigkeiten. Die einzelnen Dinger sind gar nicht so schlimm, aber das geht mir jetzt einfach auf den Keks. Ich hab so gar keine Lust derzeit. Dann drehen deine CPU runter, wenn dein Akku alt ist. Naja, das macht ja auch Sinn. Ja, wenn man mir das vorher ansagt, mir einen Schalter dafür gibt, finde ich das cool. Nicht, wenn sie das unter meinem Arsch machen. Ja, das haben sie jetzt verstanden. Ja, das haben sie jetzt verstanden, nachdem sie dank amerikanischem Rechtssystem wie dräuft sich Sammelklang am Arsch haben. Aber das sind lauter so Kleinigkeiten. Oder ich bin es jetzt auch irgendwie leid. Theoretisch müsste ich jetzt auch irgendwann mal mittelfristig mal in Rente gehen. Und ich sag mir einfach, wenn mein MacBook Pro den Abgang macht, dann höre ich einfach auf mit dem Scheiß. Weil ganz ehrlich, ich fange jetzt nicht nochmal an, mich an Thinkpad oder Windows oder Linux auf dem Thinkpad zu gewöhnen oder so ein Scheiß. Und wenn ich dann nicht nochmal schaffe, irgendwie einen MacBook Pro mit Escape-Taste zu kaufen zu dem Zeitpunkt, dann wartet.
Das wiederum kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Also mit Touchbar werde ich auch nicht alt.
Nicht nur wegen der Touchbar, ich brauche die scheiß Escape-Taste. Auch wenn die Jungs in Cupertino meinten, das ist Outbacken, das stimmt alles, das ist alles okay. Die Leute lächeln mich so immer an, wenn ich sage, ja mein Editor ist wie ein Ei. Dann gucken sie mich immer so an, als wäre ich der Zauberer von Ost oder so. Aber ich brauche dafür eine Escape-Taste. Und wenn ich keinen Laptops mehr mit Escape-Taste kaufen kann, außer einen Thinkpad, auf den ich den Linux draufspielen müsste, weil Windows kommt mir echt nicht mehr in den Schoß, dann, pff, äh, sorry, dann wartet. Dann mach ich was mit Holz und kleinen Tieren.
Ja, aber selbst die Variante mit der Escape-Taste hat ja diese fürchterlichen Tasten. Also in der Firma hab ich ja den Rechner, der steht nur auf seinem Ständer und ich hab die externe Tastatur. Und ich hab jetzt trotzdem gemerkt...
Du bist noch viel jünger als ich.
Vor ein paar Tagen, dass die H-Taste nicht mehr richtig funktioniert. Also wenn man so tippt, dass es nicht am anderen Ende des Großraumbüros zu hören ist, dann geht sie nicht. Wenn du natürlich da drauf hämmerst, wie ein Beklopter, dann geht sie schon.
Ja, und also scheiße.
Ich wollt jetzt erstmal diese Telefon frei geben.
Egal, also Telefon frei geben. Du gibst es jetzt frei, du hast es jetzt zertifiziert.
Am Anfang hab ich mich sehr schwergetan damit, weil es war einfach zu groß. Und es ist immer noch zu groß. Es ist mir eigentlich zu groß.
Du wolltest doch doch was Großes haben. Was macht mich aber nicht nass?
Nein, ich wollte einen größeren Bildschirm haben. Das heißt ja nicht, dass er gleich so groß sein müsste.
Moment, Moment, wolltest du einen physisch größeren Bildschirm haben oder einen mit mehr Pixeln?
Bei Retina ist mehr Pixel nicht mehr so richtig sinnvoll.
Das würde sich irgendwie bedingen. Also es ging mehr um Qualität und physikalische Dimension des Bildschirms.
Also du wolltest ein größeres Telefon haben?
Ja, wo man...
Dann hast du ein Problem damit, dass du ein größeres Telefon hast.
Nein, ich wollte einen größeren Bildschirm haben. Ich hätte ja, ich kann mir ja auch, also ich finde das iPhone X an sich ganz okay, aber ich könnte mir ja auch ein kleineres Gerät vorstellen, was immer noch so einen großen Bildschirm hat, wie zum Beispiel dein Telefon.
Wenn man den so rauszieht zur Seite?
Nein, du hast ja da diese Bezzles, die ich nicht habe. So, da ist ja sozusagen verbrauchter Platz. So, das heißt man könnte auch das Telefon kleiner machen, weil ja Homebutton und so weiter wegfällt. Und dann hörst du halt nur das Hörnchen da oben.
Hörnchen dachte ich würde mich mehr stören.
Nee, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Stört mich aber gar nicht. Fand ich wirklich interessant.
Das guckt man sich innerhalb von einem Tag weg.
Ja, ich sehe es, aber ich dachte es stört, weil es irgendwie so wieder die Natur ist, dass ein Bildschirm nicht viereckig ist.
Tut es aber nicht, ne?
Ja, das ist das Merkwürdige. Also das ist irgendwie auch okay. Und ich muss sagen, eigentlich ist das ja aus Apples Position heraus ganz pfiffig, weil sie es natürlich jetzt wieder geschafft haben, das iPhone wieder ikonisch aussehen zu lassen. Also du hast diesen Bildschirmausschnitt auf Fotos und jeder weiß sofort iPhone.
Ja, wäre stimmt.
Vorher war so dieses generische unten Button, oben Viereck, das ist schon so das generische Smartphone-Logo geworden. Und auch ein normales iPhone 8 sieht halt nicht anders aus als generisches Smartphone. Da ist nichts dran, was irgendwie nach iPhone aussieht. Und durch das Hörnchen haben sie das jetzt irgendwie wieder hinbekommen. Aber das ist nur so ein Nebenaspekt, der mich ja eigentlich nicht interessieren sollte. Was ist mir noch aufgefallen? Es hat mir doch sehr zugesagt, dass diese Pixel so sehr an einen heranrücken. Also ich finde diesen OLED-Bildschirm, der sieht wirklich faszinierend gut aus.
Das war da oben oder was?
Naja, für mich, ich meine, das mag sich bei euch schon so ein bisschen geändert haben, in den Modellen dazwischen. Aber ich war ja noch so auf SE. Und da sind so gefühlt die Pixel halt weiter unter dem Glas.
Ja, das ist alles...
Und ich finde, es sieht bei dem S schon so aus, als wäre es wirklich so eine dünne Schicht, die oben so drauf bemalt ist. Also ich finde es...
Bei dem X meinst du?
Ja, was sag ich gerade? Nein, bei dem X ist irgendwie alles oben drauf und da gehört es irgendwie auch hin. Und es hilft auch dabei, dieses eigentlich recht hässliche Case, was ich jetzt hier drumherum habe, zu akzeptieren, weil zumindest der Bildschirm so wirkt...
Das hat diese Standard-Negative gemeint.
Was für ein Case hast du denn?
Black Leather oder wie?
Ich finde das Leather-Case aber ganz gut. Und vor allem ich finde gut, dass es endlich wieder Product Red gibt. Weil das ist eine ordentliche Farbe. Diese ganze Pastel-Gedöns...
Nee, das geht gar nicht.
Das ist mir alles zu viel Waldorf-Kindergarten. Also das ist mir... das geht nicht.
Machen wir mal den Experten.
Ich hab das Rot für mein iPad gewählt. Und das fand ich auch sehr gut, aber ich hab jetzt trotzdem schwarz genommen. Dann die Sache mit der Kamera.
Mit welcher?
Mit der Kamera, die dein Gesicht erkennt und dieser nicht vorhandene Homebutton. Also, die kleinen Scheißer scheinen das ganz gut hinbekommen zu haben. Ich hab echt nicht mehr gemacht, als einmal mit meiner Nase gedreht. Und es gab natürlich in den ersten Tagen auch so einen ich hab dich nicht erkannt-Ding so, aber umso mehr man das halt ein zweites Mal gemacht hat etc. umso weniger wird das. Und mittlerweile finde ich, ist die Erkennungsrate okay. Das ist immer so eine Sache, ob man... Ich glaube man...
Ist sie gefühlt besser als die Erkennungsrate von dem Fingerabdrucksensor?
Ja, weil es natürlich auch funktioniert mit Handschuhen, es funktioniert mit schweißnassen Fingern.
Ach, ihr seht von solchen Schweinkramen. Aber wenn du das einfach nur tagsüber eine Handtaste anmachst, wie häufig...
Ja, besser als beim SE auf jeden Fall. Aber auch darüber hinaus auch in Situationen, wo Touch einfach sowieso nie funktioniert hätte.
Also im Vergleich zum iPad Pro zum Beispiel, würde ich sagen, funktioniert schlechter. Das Touch ID vom iPad Pro funktioniert einfach ohne, dass ich da irgendwas machen muss.
Ja, das ist dann auch für die neue Generation, die bei den späteren Telefonen ist. Der SE hat ja noch so diesen...
Ich hab weder beim iPad Pro noch beim 6S da welche Sorgen mit. Deswegen frag ich, weil da hat man sich jetzt so dran gewöhnt. Das hatte auch so seine Stolper-Schritte am Anfang und so, aber das geht jetzt halt einfach so.
Also so feuchte Finger, das ist eigentlich immer so ein bisschen, das ist der Downer gewesen bei Touch ID, wo ich mir gesagt habe, das ist jetzt eigentlich blöd, weil dann sitzt er da und versucht dich zu entschwitzen.
Sag mal, nicht so nervös!
Du musst ja jetzt nur schnell auf deine Daten zugreifen. Und das entfällt halt hier komplett. Es funktioniert im Dunkeln gut, es funktioniert im Hellen. Bisher war ich noch in keinen extremen hellen Situationen.
Nee, aber bei mir funktioniert es definitiv nicht so gut. Also ich bin ständig dabei, das Ding einzutippen, weil er mich nicht erkennt.
Vielleicht, weil du so ein aller Welts Gesicht hast?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Na klar, was soll es denn sonst sein?
Vielleicht nochmal aufsetzen?
Ja, hab ich ja schon zweimal gemacht. Wurde ja nicht besser.
Echt? Es erkennt mich mit Mütze, es erkennt mich mit...
Vielleicht bist du die aller Weltsack-Presser.
Mit der Hand im Gesicht.
Da geht bei mir gar nichts. Wenn ich irgendwie die Hand nur so halb ans Gesicht tue, geht gar nichts. Das ist irgendwie...
Denken, das geht auch mit Denken. Also, ich kann nur berichten, wie es mir geht und mir geht es so schlecht nicht. Dann dieser ganze Gestenapparat, der da dranhängt, da kann man sich auch dran gewöhnen. Das hat sogar seine Vorteile.
Ja, die sind ja auch nicht ganz doof.
Die sind nicht ganz doof, ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig. Manchmal ist es ein bisschen hm, aber dann ist es eigentlich auch sonst auch ein bisschen hm gewesen. Da kann man auch noch eine Menge verbessern. Und es ist schon erstaunlich, dass sie das hinbekommen haben.
Ja, das Einzige ist das Apps beenden. Das nervt mich ein bisschen. Aber ansonsten ist der Gestenapparat okay.
Was genau nervt dich da dran?
Ich kann die App nicht nach oben ziehen, um sie zu beenden. Du musst ja vorher drücken, bis dann diese Minus-Zeichen kommen. Du hältst sie ein bisschen und dann kannst du sie wegsliden. Wenn du sie normal wegsliden versuchst, kommst du zurück zum Homescreen.
Habe ich jetzt nicht so drunter gelitten, weil ehrlich gesagt, richtig killen muss man ja auch selten.
Und was halt auch nur so mäßig funktioniert, oder es könnte besser funktionieren, ist dieses, äh, den Screen so halb nach unten fahren.
Ach so, ja, wir nennen sie das doch gleich, Reachability.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das habe ich noch gar nicht so oft benutzt. Das könnte unter Umständen sogar meine Schmerzen noch ein bisschen erniedrigen.
Das ist ganz okay. Das ist ganz okay. Du hast da sogar den Vorteil, wenn du dieses Ding da, dieses Reachability halb runterziehst, kannst du hier oben in der Ecke, also auf der halben Höhe, auf der Ecke nach unten ziehen und kriegst dann dieses, wie heißt das, Control Center? Das heißt Control Center.
Ach so.
Das fand ich ganz nett.
Ah ja, das ist auch cool. Ja, das ist einfach der Rand des Telefons, wird nach unten verlegt. Und das ist auch nicht schlecht. Also ich bin ein bisschen überrascht. Mir missfällt eigentlich, außer der physikalischen Größe, mittlerweile eigentlich nichts mehr. Und was ich auch sehr zu schätzen gelernt habe, ist, meine Touch-ID mag zwar funktionieren, aber gerade wenn man so zwischen vielen Apps hin und her wechselt, die alle noch mal ihre eigene Unlocking-Geschichte haben. One Password, hier noch mal irgendwie für dein One-Time-Password-Dingsy und deine Online-Banking-App und all diese ganzen Tools, die noch mal so eine eigene Authentication haben wollen. Jetzt guckst du halt einfach weiterhin auf dein Telefon und es ist halt auch alles authenticated. Du musst nicht immer noch mal deine Hand auf den Button legen, um das noch mal freizuschalten, noch mal freizuschalten, sondern du merkst eigentlich gar nicht, dass Authentication... Also siehst, dass es... Da muss ich aber auch sagen, ein Gerät, was den Anspruch hat, dein permanenter Begleiter zu sein, das muss genau an der Stelle smooth sein, wo es mich halt auch die ganze Zeit begleitet. Wenn du dann immer wieder so kleine ruppige...
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ja nicht smooth. Man muss halt immer mehrmals versuchen. Also ich muss es immer mehrmals versuchen.
Ja, ich akzeptiere, dass das bei dir etwas anders ist. Bei mir, ich erkenne das jetzt hier auch mit dem Headset, irgendwie ohne Probleme. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht...
Die Frage ist, ob es jetzt auch mich für dich erkennt, weil die jetzt so fuzzy ist.
Das weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, kannst du ausprobieren. Bitte schön, anlocken sie nochmal.
Das muss man jetzt einfach nur hochnehmen und angrinsen, ne?
Also ich hab das Gefühl, die Erkennungsrat ist besser, wenn man wirklich oben in die Notch reinguckt. Also es ist wahrscheinlich dieses, du bist jetzt hier anwesend, Überprüfung, aber ansonsten... Also wenn ich einfach nur so gucke...
Also er erkennt mich nicht, wenn ich die Augen so zugeschlossen habe. Also als ich so mega müde war unterwegs und morgens und so, dann macht man so... Ich meine mal ehrlich gesagt, man hat die Augen auch noch nicht offen genug, um wirklich was zu erkennen. Also ein bisschen weiter aufmachen kann man sie dann schon. Aber ich fand es dann schon ganz interessant, dass er mich dann irgendwie nicht erkannt hat.
Das ist jetzt genau der Punkt, wofür ich Siri benutze. Siri, wie spät ist es?
Ja, also was soll ich sagen? Es hat viel Platz. Die Kamera ist toll.
Die Kamera ist unglaublich.
Die hinten jetzt?
Die hinten, ja.
Wir haben hier nachtfotos gemacht. Dann gibt es halt diesen Porträtmodus jetzt auch vorne. Das ist schon ganz nice.
Also hier dieses Crash-Foto von mir, das ist ja auch nachts gewesen. Das ist schon fast fotografisch wertvoll, fand ich. Irgendwo hier im Chat war es ja vorhin gewesen. Da muss man schon sagen, das ist schon ein gutes Foto. Dafür, dass es eigentlich nur eine Handy-Kamera ist.
Ich zeige euch hier mal Paris, überschwemmtes Paris bei Nacht.
Auch schön. Zeig es mal den Hörern.
Guck dir mal die Details an. Also das kann ich...
Ich hab da Tagesbilder von gesehen.
Das hau ich mal in den Chat hier, das Bild, das ist wirklich grandios.
Wie gesagt, hier bei dem Crash-Bild auch nachts. Man kann halt auch gute Details erkennen, die man so genau gar nicht sehen möchte. Hat das auch geflasht denn dabei? Äh, nee, ich glaub nicht, das hatte ich aus. Ich hab den Flash eigentlich immer aus. Das fliegt immer noch. Der VW-Bus hat ja auch immer noch das Licht an. Also so ist es jetzt nicht.
So, Paris bei Nacht mit iPhone X oder X.
In die Katze rein.
In die Katze rein, na super. Ja, bei den Franzosen. Da meint jemand immer noch das arme Auto.
In der Katze bitte, ja.
In der Katze rein.
So, ein Foto ausgewählt.
Triebwerk wieder an.
Aber kommt nicht, wieso kommt es nicht?
Mikrolino. Wie der Spummits als Zoja-Satz, der Mikrolino. Den kann man nicht kaufen. Morgen. Sonst passen da auch keine zwei Kinder rein. Kannst vergessen. Also.
Ach der Steffen ist auch mal wieder da. Hallo Steffen.
Sonst könnte ich auch einen Twitzi nehmen. Aber da passen eben auch keine zwei Kinder rein.
Anhänger. Doch, keine Anhängerkupplung.
Sharing funktioniert nicht. Na, grandios. Dann machen wir das mal andersrum. Ich bin ja so ein großer Freund von den Share Sheets, aber irgendwie scheinen die ja noch nicht so perfekt.
Ich sag mal so, die Elektroautos, für die es eine Anhängerkupplung gibt, da brauch ich glaube ich keinen Anhänger.
So Tim, die Sendung hat gerade Längen. Ein Huckel würde jetzt mit dem Kopf auf die Tischplatte aufschlagen.
So.
Erstmal das schöne Foto raussuchen.
Welches MacBook hat denn jetzt noch die gute Tastatur, schreibt jemand? Ganz einfach, alle die, die noch das gute USB haben.
Achso, daran macht man das fest, ja?
Ja, USB-C haben nur die mit der schrottigen Tastatur.
Siehst du zum Beispiel, daran kann man mein Desinteresse verfolgen oder erkennen, dass ich diese Entwicklung überhaupt nicht mehr weiter verfolge. Jetzt gucke ich, welches Modell hat jetzt Watt und hin und her. Mein MacBook Pro aus 2010 funktioniert noch 1A. Wuppt auch noch.
Meinst du das 2011 auch? Oder 11? Nein, Ende 2013. Das ist ja ein Jüngelchen.
So, jetzt habe ich hoffentlich mein Upload hier gleich durch.
Da sind sie, da ist Le Paris.
Genau, also das fand ich dann doch schon ganz überzeugend. Mit anderen Worten, iPhone X ist freigegeben, könnt ihr kaufen.
Jetzt sind die Warteschlangen auch nicht mehr so groß.
Ja, ich habe das auch schnell bekommen. Es ist natürlich arschteuer, so mal ehrlich. Das kostet eine Menge Holz. Das ist schon krass, dass man da eigentlich genau so viel ausgibt, wie man sonst für seinen Laptop ausgegeben hat. Das fällt bei mir jetzt auf jeden Fall ein bisschen unter Luxus. Und ich habe natürlich auch noch sozusagen zwei Jahre lang jetzt auch nicht gekauft bzw. eigentlich war ich jetzt dann doch sehr sparsam. Ich weiß gar nicht, wenn ich das letzte Mal ein High-End-iPhone gekauft habe. Das ist schon eine Weile her. Insofern hoffe ich, mich da jetzt ausreichend rausgeredet zu haben. Aber ihr müsst ja sowieso selber wissen, was ihr am besten findet. Ich wollte das jetzt mal haben. Und ganz ehrlich, ich habe damit gerechnet, dass ich es zurückgebe. Davon bin ich ausgegangen. Das war die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen meine Prämisse.
Das war deine Hoffnung.
Chet sagt, es ist ein Laptop, der täglich meist benutzte. Hast du eine Ahnung, wie oft ich mein Laptop benutze?
Hier, Paris bei Nacht, drei Linden bei Nacht.
Nee, nee, also mein Laptop ist... Also wenn ich unterwegs bin, definitiv das Telefon meist benutzt. Wenn ich nicht unterwegs bin, dann sind meine Macs definitiv benutzer als meine iPhones. Davon könnt ihr mal ausgehen. Und wenn Apple sich nicht langsamer zusammenrauft und mal wieder einen richtigen Laptop baut, der diesen Namen auch verdient mit Escape-Taste oder zumindest das Pro verdient mit einer richtigen Tastatur, mit einem ordentlichen Bildschirm und ordentlichen Ports, wenn ihr das nicht hinkriegt innerhalb der nächsten zwei, drei Jahre...
Merkst du was? Du wünschst dir jetzt einfach nur wieder alte Zeug zurück. Wir sind jetzt schon so weit früher, haben wir gekwängelt, dass wir sagen, Alter, wann kommt jetzt endlich das eingebaute LTE-Modem oder sowas? Mit solchen Wünschen befassen wir uns schon gar nicht mehr. Wir wünschen uns eigentlich nur noch sehentlich, dass sie mal zu ihrer alten Glory zurückkehren. Und wir brauchen... Ja, aber so schlimm ist das schon. Ich fände das sehr bedenklich. Ich hab jetzt aber auch keinen Bock mehr, da jetzt dauernd gegen anzurenten. Deswegen sag ich, wenn mein MacBook Pro den Abschied macht, nehme ich dieses komische Air, was ich hier mal geerbt habe vor ein paar Jahren und mach damit meine Projekte zu und dann mach ich was mit Holz und kleinen Tieren.
Also ich hab ja, ich hab auf dem vorletzten Kongress, da gab's ja, da gab's ja diese komischen gefakten Stiftung Warentest-Aufkleber. 5,0, nicht so geil, stand da drauf. Und so ein, das ist bei mir der einzige Aufkleber, der auf dem... Oder 6,0, genau. Den hab ich auf das Firmen MacBook drauf gemacht, als einzigen Aufkleber. Sehr viele Kollegen sind neidisch.
Da fallen Dinge ab von der Rakete.
Ja, die sind jetzt fast durch hier mit ihrem SpaceX-Launch. Ja, vielleicht beim Let's Play.
Das fand ich immer ganz nett. Ich hab mal so ein Ding mal gesehen, das war auch in der Nacht oder so ein bisschen langweilig gehabt. Oder Jetlag von irgendwann. Und dann hab ich denen zugeguckt, wie sie mal so mehrfache Satelliten rausstoßen. Wenn sie mal so 10 von den Beestern an Bord haben. Das find ich eigentlich auch ganz spannend. Und welchen Heile noch rum?
36.000 Kilometer entfernt.
So jetzt frag ich mich, was macht jetzt dieses Stück Rakete da noch? Das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich deorbitieren, oder?
Das deorbitiert jetzt.
Das zeigen sie aber nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die in die Erde eintreten oder ob die sich sozusagen auch einfach in Parkpositionen bringen. Weil von 36.000 Kilometer ist es wieder zurück. Das ist auch ein langer Weg. Dann schieben die sich lieber ins All.
Na ja, mit einer entsprechenden Parabel könnte man das schon machen.
Ja, aber warum wird es dann nicht auch mit allen anderen Satelliten gemacht?
Du hast mit den Leos noch ein anderes Problem. Da ist halt die Mülldichte höher als bei 36.000. Du kannst recht haben, dass du sagen kannst, jetzt sind wir eh schon so weit weg, dem Ding noch einen Tritt zu geben, dass wir einfach raus ins All fliegen. Ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so...
Na ja, ins All fliegen sie ja nicht.
Es ist weniger als das Ding wieder runterzubremsen, dass wir das schön verglühen lassen können.
Also ins All fliegen sie ja nicht. Sie haben ja einen Parkorbit, der ist oberhalb dem geostationären Orbit. Und dadurch, dass der so weit draußen ist, und dann kälte er halt so gut wie gar nicht. Dann bleibt das Zeug halt da oben.
Und trifft hoffentlich keinen anderen.
Und gammelt vor sich hin. So, was haben wir denn noch Schönes? Haben wir noch Themen?
Hab ich hier nicht mal von so einem Workflow offen. Da ist ein Workflow.
Ah ja, genau. Sollten wir vielleicht noch erwähnen. Hier, alle Podcaster, ne? Ultraschall, die tolle Software, die hier unter anderem gerade diese Sendung aufnimmt. Hat vor kurzem ein Update bekommen auf die gloriose Versionsnummer 3.1. Und ich muss mal ein Lob aussprechen, dem Team, weil ich hab den ja, also ich hab das begleitet, bin aber auch nicht auch nur ansatzweise so involviert wie alle anderen.
Das ist jetzt das Codename BDR Release.
Der Name klingt wohl rum.
Nee, dann werden ja nicht released.
Also es gibt ja ein Release-Name, die haben immer so strange Release-Names. Heißt ja so wie Miedinger.
Nee, nee, Codename sag ich ja.
Ja, aber damit hat es ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig zu tun.
Sie haben sich auch ein bisschen gequält, ne? Habt man so den Eindruck?
Ja, gequält im Sinne von Mühe gegeben.
Ja, ja, ja, wie nicht. Aber war eine schwere Geburt. Eine lange Geburt.
Hat auf jeden Fall ein bisschen gedauert, aber das Ding will Weile haben und es ist auf jeden Fall auch so ein richtig schönes Refinement. Und es sind zahlreiche Sachen drin, auf die ich dringlich gewartet habe. Von daher ist sozusagen auch mein Input in diesem Release etwas versenkt worden, was mich natürlich besonders freut. Also jetzt ist das wirklich... Also bisher war es nur geil und jetzt ist es richtig geil. Das ist schon nochmal so eine nennenswerte Steigerung. Ich will jetzt gleich die ganzen Features runterbeten. Es gibt da ein ausführliches Release-Video, was Ralf gemacht hat, auf Ultraschall FM alles zu finden, da...
Eine Siri-Integration? Gibt da auch Siri für OS X oder für Mac OS?
Siri-Integration, was soll das heißen? Siri-Integration.
Dass man so mitten in dem Podcast spricht, so Kapitelmarke und dann macht man das jetzt...
Soll ich für dich nach Freak Show im Internet suchen? Nicht.
Soll ich nach Kapitelmarke im Internet suchen?
Es sind viele Details, es ist jetzt sehr nördig, das alles wiederzugeben. Ich persönlich freue mich vor allem über den grandiosen Follow-Modus, womit sozusagen eines der wenigen Features, die ich nach wie vor vermisst habe aus meiner alten Ableton Live-Zeit, auch bei Ultraschall, Einzug gehalten habe. Was macht das denn? Das Follow ist einfach, ich kann so mit Apfel F den Modus an- und ausschalten. Das ist so, wenn du mal kurz auf das Recording guckst, jetzt ist sozusagen immer der aktuelle Recording-Point in der Mitte und alles zieht so nach links.
Du verschwindest jetzt die Hälfte deines Bildschirms rechts, weil da ist nichts zu sehen, was sinnvoll wäre.
Die Aufteilung würde ich noch gerne auf 90-10 machen, aber das lässt sich derzeit noch nicht ändern, weil das Reaper einfach nicht macht. Aber wenn ich jetzt hier meinen Follow-Modus ausschalte, dann wird das hier nicht nur visuell wiedergegeben, dann bleibt das sozusagen stehen, diese ganze Autoscrolling-Geschichte. Das heißt, wenn man während der Aufnahme rumeditieren will, das will man schon mal manchmal, Kapitelmarker in die richtige Stelle schieben und so was, dann kann man das halt jetzt irgendwie mal eben machen. Jetzt will ich aber auch sehen, dass er aufzeichnet, dass ich dann wieder abfüllen kann. Und dann ist er zack wieder da.
Wie Finde.
Wie Follow.
Wie Find. In allen anderen Apps.
Oder halt Follow, wenn Find keinen Sinn macht, weil...
Okay, ja, verstehe. Kann das denn jetzt eigentlich Fullscreen-Modus? Es gibt ja von diesen Apples diesen tollen Fullscreen-Modus, wenn du auf den grünen Knopf oben drauf gehst, dass du sozusagen den ganzen Blödsinn einnimmst. Guck mal, was du da noch an Screen Space gewonnen hast.
Ja, nee, das ist auch ganz sinnvoll, dann kann man auch besser davon weg wechseln und so.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, also da gibt da noch wirklich eine ganze Latte von Details, die aber jetzt sagen wir mal nur für Leute relevant sind, die jetzt wirklich damit regelmäßig arbeiten, aber für die ist einfach eine Menge dabei. Und das ist einfach...
Da ist schon viel Schönes dabei.
Sehr schön zu sehen, wie viel Power das irgendwie so entwickeln kann, wenn da erst mal genug Leute drauf sind. Ich hoffe, dass wir dann so für unsere Next-Generation-Podlauf-Geschichte ähnlich beeindrucken können.
Szenenapplaus, genau. So, sind wir fertig oder was?
Na, mir brennt jetzt nicht so dringend viel unter den Nägeln.
Achso, aber wir wollten noch mal, doch, ich wollte noch mal eine Sache, nee, zwei Sachen ansprechen. Nämlich diese Sache mit dem Ich will meinen Rechner erreichen. Ich weiß, wir haben vorhin schon drüber gesprochen, aber ich denke, das ist für die Sendung auch noch mal ganz interessant. So, überhaupt so eigener Scheiß im Netz, sagen wir es mal so. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weit gegriffen, ne? Ich stelle immer wieder fest, dass dieses Ganze Back to my Mac auf dem Mac einfach, das bringt mich vielleicht irgendwo hin, aber nicht zu meinem Mac. Und ich verstehe das nicht. Das war irgendwie am Anfang war das irgendwie, als das rauskam, war das irgendwie okay. Und jetzt ist es irgendwie...
Peak Apple.
Weiß ich nicht genau, woran das liegt, aber...
Also man kann das bestimmt träsen. Also wenn du mir jetzt vormachen würdest, wovon die Hörer jetzt natürlich nichts haben, aber wenn du mir jetzt vormachst, dass das nicht geht, und du jetzt ubertrabst in ein anderes LAN, WLAN oder LTE und dann versuchst du dich back to my Mac'en oder sonst immer, dann kann man da mit ein bisschen Wireshark oder so schon dahinter kommen, warum das nicht geht. Aber das ist natürlich trotzdem mühsam. Ich sehe das schon ein.
Ja.
Ich meine, das Mittel der Wahl immer dafür ist...
Also ich hab jetzt zwei Macs, wenn die beide laufen, kann ich den einen erreichen, den anderen nicht. Das ist irgendwie schon mal...
Vielleicht war das nicht vorgesehen. Vielleicht hat Apple nicht mit ihrem Erfolg gerechnet, dass sich jemand mehr als einen Mac kauft.
Die Frage ist ja eigentlich eher, was ist eigentlich so der Pfad, den man folgen sollte, wenn man seinen Rechner zuhause erreichen will. So, und zwar einen beliebigen Rechner zuhause erreichen will. So man hat da sozusagen so sein Netzwerk und man möchte irgendwie auf diese Büchsen zugreifen. Mindestens so wie SSH, im Idealfall halt.
Das ist jetzt aber inzwischen ein Sharing. Ein, wie würde man sagen, ein ungewöhnliches Setup geworden.
Wieso?
Einen Rechner zu haben, der zuhause ist und auch immer noch an, ist in 2018 Alien. Sorry bitte, das ist... Ich hab sowas schon seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr. Weil ich erstens den Krach nicht haben will und weil ich festgestellt hab, dass Strom auch teuer ist. Das wusste ich auch schon, bevor ich einen Tesla gekauft habe, aber... Ich halte noch einfach für albern, zuhause rumrabbelnde Maschinen zu haben. Wir sind heute in einer Zeit, wo du dir für 2,59 Euro per Hez nach VM klicken kannst, wo du deinen ganzen Scheiß drauf spielen kannst, der Tag und Nacht läuft, der ist dann auch immer lustig erreichbar und so.
Ich kann meine Rechner ja auch aus der Ferne einschalten, wenn ich sie brauche.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass deine Anforderungen jetzt völlig aus der Welt gegriffen haben, aber es ist halt eben...
Ich bin es gewohnt, mein Leben ist gepflastert von solchen Problemen, wie du, hat kein Mensch, Tim.
Mehr, mehr. Die hatten wir alle mal, als wir alle mal Rechner draußen hatten.
Früher war es immer noch nicht, jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr.
Naja, das Mittel der Wahl dort, um das Problem grundsätzlich anzunehmen, weil muss jetzt nicht der Rechner sein, kann ja auch the latest Internet of Shit sein. Kann ja sein, dass du jetzt aus der Ferne diese Glühbirne irgendwie auf Lila stellen willst, die da über uns hängt. So Zeugs. Das Mittel der Wahl dort der Industrie ist, dass sie einfach sagen, wir verbinden uns die ganze Internet of Shit und auch deine Mac-Rechner, verbinden sich alle mit der Cloud. Das heißt, du kümmerst dich einfach gar nicht mehr drum. Und du redest halt nur noch über die Cloud mit den Dingern. Warum das keine gute Idee ist, hatten wir schon ein paar Mal. Müssen wir jetzt nicht weiter elaborieren. Und das natürlich auch nicht so gut funktioniert. Das ist eine andere. Die andere traditionelle Methode, wie man das macht, ist, sich einen VPN zu bauen. Da gibt es jetzt die High-End-Nerd-Variante mit IKE, V2, Soße und Schaf und so. Dann gibt es sozusagen die mittelsimple Variante, rein IPv4 basiert. Du gehst in deine Fritzbox, klickst an, ja, ich möchte VPN haben. Und dann kriegst du da so ein Set von Informationen, die sie dir auch zum Ausdrucken sozusagen vorschlagen, die du einfach an deinen Mac einklopfst und dann ist es fine. Dann hast du aber nur V4.
Ja, aber VPN heißt ja dann, dass ich dann nur noch exklusiv darüber sozusagen meine Netau habe.
Nicht notwendigerweise, nee. Aber bei diesen Dingern ist das so. Du hast halt das Problem, dass eigentlich, was du haben willst, ist so ein Splitt-Tunnel-VPN. Das heißt, du möchtest einen VPN haben, der nur bestimmten Verkehr dahin macht. Das ist deswegen ein bisschen problematisch, weil so waren VPNs eigentlich früher immer gedacht. Jetzt gibt es inzwischen, was viele Leute, auch gerade viele Hörer aus der Twitter-Filter-Bubble, wenn die VPN hören, denken sie, ach, der Mechanismus, der mir erlaubt, amerikanische Säen bei Dollar Provider anzugucken, wie beam ich mich nach Amerika, damit meine IP-Location mich nicht verpetzt. Was zwar dieselbe Technik ist, aber eine andere Anwendung. Was du halt haben willst, ist so ein klassischer Splitt-Tunnel-VPN. Das heißt, du hast hier ein kleines Firmennetzwerk und möchtest nur den Verkehr für dieses kleine Netzwerk über den Tunnel hier rein VPN haben. Der Rest des Internets soll vielleicht da bleiben, wo er ist. Das kann man auch bauen. Das unterstützt auch Apple mit den Dingen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die Fritzbox auch Splitt-Tunnel macht. Ich glaube, macht sie nicht, weil das eine proprietäre Cisco-Erweiterung ist bei dem normalen IKE V1, die aber natürlich die Open-Source-Gemeinde längst nachgebaut hat. Oder man nutzt eben ein ganz anderes, ein bisschen moderneres VPN, was jetzt auch nicht in deiner Fritzbox wohnt, weil du sagst, du hast hier eh mal einen Rechner am Start. Dann kannst du auch mit so etwas spielen wie OpenVPN. Oder halt mit so ein bisschen Exoten, aber dafür noch jünger und eigentlich auch ganz lustig wie Tink. Oder WireGuard, wären jetzt die User. Nimm doch WireGuard, ist egal. Es gibt so eine Klasse von jüngeren VPNs, die zwar auch schon eine Weile da sind. Tink gibt es auch schon seit ein paar Jährchen. Wo halt die Leute sagen, wir hatten einfach keinen Bock hier auf IKE und komische Parameter einstellen und schlimmstenfalls mit ZDV-Karten rumhantieren und machen und tun und so. Und das ist immer noch so die Methode, wie komme ich von draußen hier rein?
Also Tink ist T-I-N-C. Tink, tincstrichvpn.org.
Ich mag Tink, deswegen aber einfach aufzusetzen ist. Du brauchst halt nicht rumhantieren mit Zertifikaten oder Tralala oder sowas. Vor allen Dingen, weil das ein, also erstmal grundsätzlich, ist es ein Punkt zum Multipunkt VPN. Das heißt, du hast nicht so den einen Tunnel, sondern du hast halt N Mitspieler. Bei drei Mitspielern beispielsweise hast du automatisch drei Tunnel. Wenn du so ein Dreieck dir vorstellst, hat es dann sozusagen drei Kanten. Und wenn du halt vier Mitspieler hast, hast du implizit sechs Kanten und so. Oder sechs Linien, wenn du so willst, Verbindungslinien.
Also jeder mit jedem.
Jeder mit jedem. Die bilden sich von alleine. Das heißt, du musst die nicht alle einzeln konfigurieren und so. Und hat auch noch ein paar andere Lucid Features. Und was ich auch daran mag, ist, man kann es im Layer-2-Modus betreiben. Das heißt, wenn du eh schon so ein jeder mit jedem...
So ein digitaler Swingerclub.
Ja, wenn man so will. Du kannst es als Layer-2-VPN benutzen, das heißt als Ethernet. Das heißt, du hast jeder zu jeder Verbindung, wie man es auch gewohnt ist, so wie an so einem Ethernet. Das ist der Internet-Switch und das hilft dir natürlich gerade, wenn du mit Internet of Shit oder mit Apple-Kram zu tun hast und jetzt aus welchen Gründen auch immer aus der Ferne per, wie heißt es, Air, nee, Air, nicht Airprint, Airprint auch, aber Airplay, Airplay für Audio und Video und diesen ganzen anderen. Alles was man halt im lokalen Netz braucht.
Aber da hast du natürlich auch mehr Rauschen, hast natürlich mehr Treffik, weil dann auch wirklich dieser ganze Ab und sonst wie Climbim auch noch geflogen kommt.
Normalerweise, absolut, innerhalb deines Netzes ist es normalerweise relativ friedlich, wenn es eh hinter Firewalls und Nat versteckt ist, passiert da nicht so viel. Ja, das ist jetzt nicht notwendigerweise das sparsamste VPN, gerade wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel mit E-Sender Zeugs machst, dann geht schon noch ein bisschen mehr Treffik rechts und links durch. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht Mittel der Wahl, wenn man jetzt an seinem LTE-Kontingent knabbert.
Bedenken, ich habe hier natürlich auch noch mein Dante-Netzwerk.
Ja, und das macht aber viel Unicast. Das funktioniert wie eine Bridge. Und wenn du da einen Unicast-Verkehr machst, sieht das das Tink VPN nicht. Das sieht bloß deine Multicast und deine Broadcast.
Das heißt, wenn ich eine Multicast fahren würde, würde mir das dann alles durch Tink durchballern?
Das hängt davon ab, wie schlau dir deine Bridge davor gestaltet ist. Die kann ja ein IGP-Snooping machen und rausfinden, ob dein Gerät das haben will oder nicht. Ich meine, das ist jetzt schon sophisticated. Aber die Idee an Tink ist, es relativ einfach aufzusetzen. Du musst irgendwo in deinem Konglomerat ein System haben, das entweder einen konstanten DNS-Namen hat oder eine konstante IP-Adresse. Mindestens einen.
Aber es reicht dann sozusagen, dass ein Rechner in meinem lokalen Netz reingetinkt ist. Und der liefert dann quasi seine Ethernet-Sicht oder seinen Blick aufs Internet und erlaubt dem anderen Netzwerk den Zugriff darauf.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht Tink's Problem. Ich verstehe schon, was du willst. Wenn ich jetzt auf den Drucker drucken will, da ist kein Tink-Line drauf.
Und dann kann ich das nicht.
Du musst das aber ein bisschen abstrahieren. Was der Tink macht, der Tink baut dir erst mal eine zusätzliche, wenn du es im Layer-2 Modus betreibst, zusätzliche Ethernet-Schnittstelle an deinen Rechner dran.
Also an meinen Außenrechner? Oder an meinen Innenrechner?
An deinen Innenrechner. Du willst ja erst mal das Setup hier drin machen. Du baust jetzt erst mal, das klemmt dir da ein Ethernet an. Das sieht aus für deinen Rechner wie ein Ethernet. Dein Rechner, auch so ein Mac, kann Bridging. Du kannst einem Rechner sagen, bitte verbinde doch mal mein echtes Ethernet, mit dem Kabel dran, oder meinen WLAN, mit Ethernet-Schnittstelle Tink, oder wie auch immer die dann heißt. Wie heißt der dann, wie Tap 0, also auf dem Mac. Und dann verbindest du die ja miteinander. Dann kannst du auch durch diese VPN mit deinem Druckerhahn oder deinem Scanner oder deinem Mischpult, oder was auch immer reden. Das ist dann egal. Das ist genauso, als wenn du einen Switch einbauen wolltest. Also ist jetzt nicht ein Hub. Es ist schon ein bisschen intelligenter als eine Bridge.
Okay, also wenn ich dann remote da ran docke, dann sehe ich hier quasi mein komplettes Hausnetz. Und wenn sich da ein Drucker mit AirPrint meldet, dann kann ich auch dessen IP-Adresse benutzen und da was hinschicken.
V6, V4 ist dir dann auch egal? Du musst auch nicht rutschen, weil du dein Ethernet einfach nur fährst.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich jetzt hier so ein internes... Gut, ich hab jetzt hier auch V6, aber sagen wir mal, hier wäre nur so das übliche 192.168.01 Netz. Und ich hätte jetzt noch irgendwie so einen zweiten Sport, die das gleiche Netzwerk benutzen.
Dann hast du immer das Problem. Das muss verhindert werden sozusagen. Dann hast du aber auch im Routen-Modus ein Problem. Momentan, wie gesagt, verlängern wir nur Ethernetz.
Okay, also ich wollte nur fragen, ob er in irgendeiner Form noch mal selber ein Mapping macht oder ein Nuttink oder so.
Kannst du ein Spielchen machen, dann musst du das Ding aber im Routen-Modus betreiben oder auf der anderen Seite mit Nutt oder wie auch immer. Das ist übrigens auch so ein Punkt. Also diese Tink macht nicht alles für dich. Also das macht nicht dein Netzdesign, sondern das stellt dir einfach roh was zur Verfügung. Entweder ein geroutetes oder ein geswitchtes, also so ein Layer-2-Interface. Du musst dann schon noch von Hand entweder mit ifconfig oder sowas da deine IP-Adresse draufschmeißen beziehungsweise was Tink macht ist. Die haben so einen halben Dutzend Skripte, die sie zu verschiedenen Zeiten aufrufen. Und es gibt auch einen Skript, was automatisch aufgerufen wird, wenn dein Tink sich mit dem Rest deiner Wolke verbindet. Und da kannst du dann so Sachen wie ifconfig setze IP-Adresse oder wie auch immer. Oder kannst deinen DHCP Server auffordern, sich da eine Adresse zu holen oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, du musst es konfigurieren, wie du eine normale DSNET-Interface auch konfigurierst. Aber das willst du ja auch. Was der Tink-Diener macht, das stellt dir nur diese virtuelle Kabel zur Verfügung. Und der Knaller ist jetzt, wie gesagt, dass das eine Punkt-zu-Multi-Punkt-Geschichte ist. Das heißt, wenn du das machst bei hier und mit mehreren Laptops oder wie auch immer und die mehreren Laptops schwirren zum Beispiel irgendwo rum, die sehen sich auch immer über Tink direkt. Die aktuelle Version, diese Prerelease, diese 1.1.pre.15 oder so, die da gerade am Start ist, die hat auch so ein Feature drin, dass das auch rausfindet, wenn sich zwei von diesen Clients versehentlich gerade im selben Laden befinden und ruht dann auch direkt. Also da hat es ein paar ganz lustige Modi. Was ich gesagt habe, ist, es ist einfach zu konfigurieren. Du brauchst nicht 30 Millionen Libraries und noch irgendwas, was du erst mal, wenn du es selber kompilieren willst, am Start haben musst, das ist relativ self-contained. Und easy zu machen und wenn du es einmal aufgesetzt hast, ist das Hinzufügen neuer Clients extrem simpel. Im besten Fall besteht es darin, dass du auf einer Maschine sagst, ich möchte gerne jemanden neu einladen, dann generiert er so einen String, der ist so eine halbe Terminal breite lang, vom Prinzip eine IP-Adresse und dann ein Base64, blödsinn. Und dann gehst du auf den neuen Client hin und sagst Tink Join, gibst ihm diesen String und da ist alles drin, was er braucht, um sich mit dem Rest des Netzes zu verbinden. Und dann machst du halt, wie gesagt, konfigurierst du nur noch deine Ethernet-Schnittstelle, indem ihr noch eine IP-Adresse gibst oder ihr sagt, du solltest ja CP spielen oder wie auch immer.
Und die finden sich so ein bisschen wie mit BitTorrent Sync.
Ja, dazu musst du mindestens, nochmal, du musst mindestens einen Mitspieler haben in diesem Spiel, der entweder einen festen Namen hat, dünn DNS geht da auch, oder eine feste IP-Adresse oder beides. Tink benutzt selber V6, V4, das heißt, du kannst auch mit den ganzen Dingern spielen, kannst auch kreuz und quer, kannst also auch sagen, dass wenn wir jetzt hier so ein Dreieck haben, kann Roddi zu dir eine V6-Verbindung haben, ich zu dir eine V4-Verbindung und Roddi und ich haben eine V5-Verbindung, wie auch immer. Nein, aber das ist relativ flexibel dahingehend und funktioniert für mich eigentlich schon ganz gut. Weil ich, wie gesagt, den speziellen Spaß mit diesem Layer 2 benutze. Du kannst auch ganz artfremd, wir hatten uns vor etlichen Sendungen mal über LDP unterhalten, erinnerst du dich noch?
Oh ja, das hatte ich ja hier mal im Einsatz.
Ja, das hat aber, da hat der Apple was verkackt, aber egal. Grundsätzlich ist es ja keine schlechte Sache. Das funktioniert auch alles. Das funktioniert alles, was du da in deinem lokalen Laden hast. Und natürlich mit dem Delay. Klar, wenn du jetzt weiter draußen bist, wird dein Ping dadurch nicht schneller, aber das funktioniert. Du kannst halt, wenn du irgendeinen Server hast, selbst wenn du jetzt nicht am aktiven Datenverkehr teilnimmst, aber wenn du einen Server draußen hast, den du eh gemietet hast bei irgendeinem Hoster, der eine feste IP-Adresse hat oder festen Namen, der auf irgendwas hinweist, machst du da eben auch so einen Tink drauf, der dann nur als Vermittler dient für die anderen. Weil sie brauchen alle, wie du gerade sagst, sie finden sich so wie BitTorrent-Clients, aber sie brauchen irgendwo mal eine Anker. Irgendwo müssen sie mal anfangen und mal einen von sich erwischen unter einem anderen und die verteilen sich innerhalb dieses Tinknetzes, verteilt sich die Information, wer jetzt wo ist und das bohrt sich ordentlich durch Firewalls durch und diese ganzen Adaptionen, die man so macht, so als Clientel und wie gesagt, das funktioniert ganz gut für mich. Super Tipp, ich empfehle aber nichts wie immer.
Nein.
Nein, nein. Aber es ist ein lustiges Spielzeug. Reizvoll eben Punkt zu Multi-Punkt, Layer 2 kann open wie per N auch, aber es ist halt immer nur Punkt zu Punkt, das heißt, wenn du da mehr als ein System am Start hast, wartet immer ein irre Tunnelgewusel mit OpenVPN oder du hast ja irgendwie einen Stern gebaut und dann ging der ganze Verkehr durch diesen Knotenpunkt im Stern durch.
Nee, das klingt ganz sinnvoll, vor allem ich kann ja mit einem Server im Netz, wo ich irgendwie einfach sage, hier feste IP-Adresse, das agiert eigentlich mehr so als Hub. Da habe ich quasi meine Infrastruktur und dann kann ich jeden beliebigen Heimrechner, den ich erreichen will, mal eben damit einklinken, aber wenn ich mich dahin verbinde, dann tue ich das nicht über diesen Master-Server.
Vielleicht die ersten ein, zwei Pakete. Die Dinger sind wirklich darauf ausgerichtet, dass du so schnell wie möglich Verkehr hinbekommst. Das heißt, wenn du neu startest, pingst, dann hast du erst mal längere Ping-Zeiten, weil es erst mal kreuz und quer durch diese Mesh hin und her ballert, bis es herausgefunden hat, wer du bist und wo jetzt der Exit wieder ist für das, was du da machen willst. Und die, die es geschafft haben, sich direkt miteinander zu verbinden. Das ist zum Beispiel auch ein cooler Punkt. Also wenn du mit Ping machst, sind so die ersten zwei, drei, vier Pings oder so länger und dann merkst du, ah, ok, jetzt hat er einen direkten Weg gefunden. Das Interessante ist, es geht halt eben auch immer noch, wenn du jetzt hinter einer Fascho-Firewall steckst, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht mitmacht, dass du von draußen dich jetzt oder dass du dich jetzt direkt von einem anderen Client wieder connecten lässt. Dann geht es halt durch deinen Hub durch, durch dein Hubsystem. Aber es geht immer noch. Das ist vielleicht nicht trafikmäßig optimal, aber es geht.
Weißt du auf welchen Port der funkt?
Du stellst dich ein, wenn ihn in Ruhe lässt und er der Port frei ist, nimmt er 655. Für UDP und TCP. Per TCP macht er so Metaconnections, worüber sie diese ganzen Informationen austauschen, wer wann wo und wer welche Schlüssel und so weiter. Und auf UDP machen sie den reinen Packet-Transfer. Aber er geht auch automatisch auf einen anderen Port, wenn der 655 nicht da ist. Das Ding ist auch mandantenfähig. Das heißt, du kannst sagen, ich möchte gerne mehrere diverse VPNs haben. Und dann gibst du denen so einen Namen. Kannst du zum Beispiel eins Metaebene nennen. Oder wie auch immer kannst du die parallel betreiben. Und er merkt dann zum Beispiel, wenn du Metaebene zuerst aufgesetzt hast, nimmt sich dann die 655 und versuchst, die zweite aufzusetzen. Merkt er, das geht jetzt nicht, dann nimmt er sich einen anderen Port. Verteilt es aber auch über seine Meta-Connections automatisch an die anderen Dinger. Also da musst du nichts dran machen. Das ist relativ easy peasy. Gefällt mir ganz gut. Das Open Source ist auch klein. Das ist easy kompilieren. Ich hab mir das selber kompiliert für meine Edge-Router, also für die MIPS-Plattform und MIPS Little Engine. Also auch auf gerade so Edge-Router X. Diese kleinen Billig-Router für 50 Euro, oder nicht mal mehr 50 Euro, die genügend CPU-Booms dafür haben, ist eine tolle Sache.
Angeblich funktioniert es auch auf iOS, aber nur als Züdia-Package.
Ah so, iOS. Ja, das ist einer der Nachteile. Es gibt keinen offiziellen Support dafür, keine iOS-App. Wobei es keinen Grund dafür gibt. Du darfst ja als Abhersteller VPNs machen. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel einen OpenVPN-Client für iOS. Also wenn sich mal jemand hinsetzt und diesen Tink-Code nimmt und da die entsprechenden GUI oder die entsprechenden Framework-Codes drumrum macht, wird es doch nicht sofort verboten. Nö, das macht nichts Böses. Das macht nichts anderes als OpenVPN. Und wenn OpenVPN erlaubt ist, dann ist auch Tink erlaubt, theoretisch. Wenn man da eben eine Oberfläche drumrum macht.
Ich wäre schon mit richtigen Rechnern zufrieden.
Du musst ja sozusagen die Anforderungen erfüllen, die Apple anstellt an einen VPN-Client. Der muss dich anmelden, registrieren, damit du dann in dem VPN-Listen auftauchst. Ich bin zu der Frage für meine Devices. Ich hab jetzt als Arbeitsmodell am Start, dass ich auf meinen Rechnern Tink drauf habe. Auch inklusive Router und Linus-Kisten und Raspberry Pi und lalala. Da gibt es sozusagen mehrere große Lans. Da sind teilweise irgendwie 40 Geräte drin inzwischen. In diesen virtuellen Lans. Und dann habe ich an einen von denen, ist sozusagen mein Einfallstor, da läuft ein OpenVPN-Server. Und da connecte ich den halt mit iPad oder mit iPhone gegen. Und der ist sozusagen, wenn du so willst, mein VPN-Router von der iOS-Welt in die Tink-Welt.
Ja, heute geht es ja nur um Raketen. Und ich wollte dir auf diese Rakete auch noch hinweisen.
Die ist schön.
Weil die habe ich nicht. Die ist schön, ne? Die hat so genau das richtige Gewicht, genau den richtigen Füllen.
Und Gummifüße.
Und Gummifüße. Und vor allem ist es welche Rakete, Clemens?
Tantan Emilou, auf Deutsch Tim und Struppi. Das ist die Reise zum Mond.
Das sind zwei Comics aus der Serie, wo die Rakete vorkommt, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Die hast du jetzt sozusagen aus Kourou mitgeschleppt, oder aus Paris?
Nein, die ist mir in Paris.
Ist sie dir in den Einkaufsbeutel gefallen?
Ist sie mir in den Einkaufsbeutel gefallen, genau. Das ist halt aus...
Die ist wirklich sehr ironisch.
Reisezielmond, Entschuldigung. Und dann gibt es noch Schritte auf dem Mond. Da ist die dann halt auch nochmal.
Ja, wo sie dann endlich ankommen oder so.
Und naja, das ist halt eine Comic-Rakete. Sie war tatsächlich damals auch eine der Inspirationen für die Camp-Rakete für Fairy Dust, als wir die entwickelt haben. Na ja klar, ich meine, wenn du eine Rakete bauen willst und erst mal so, wie soll die überhaupt aussehen, dann guckst du natürlich erst mal an, was es gibt. Und irgendwie diese klassische Tripod-Raketen-Style, der ist natürlich schon...
Wackelt nicht.
Ja, der ist aber auch irgendwie... Ich weiß nicht genau, warum alle so auf diese Tripod... Ich meine, es gibt eigentlich bei den richtigen Raketen keine Tripods.
Ich überlege gerade, die V2, die hatte auch vier Finnen, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, ehrlich gesagt, nicht genau.
Also die V2, die gab es ja als Versuchsaggregat, hatte die ja auch dieses Schachbrettmuster. Also die war, die V2 war garantiert auch...
Ja, genau, die war so ähnlich. Ja, das ist ja die böse Rakete, ne?
Ja, naja, gut, Kriegsgerät.
Aggregat 4 hieß die ja.
Aggregat 4, ja.
Und die war sicherlich auch in der Inspiration hier, weil die halt tatsächlich auch so etwas...
Die hat vier.
So ein Muster, aber die hatte halt vier Finnen, genau.
Obwohl, das weiß man nicht.
Doch, das weiß man nicht.
Nee, das sieht man nicht.
Na hier, damit ist nix.
Eine Steuerung zu bauen für eine Rakete, die nur drei Finnen hat, wäre zur daberligen Zeit wahrscheinlich relativ schwierig gewesen. Naja, vier und rechter Winkel und so weiter ist, glaub ich, einfacher.
90 Grad, 120 Grad.
Vier Stahlruder aus Grafit.
Nicht Stahlruder, Strahlruder.
Strahlruder, ja, Stahlruder aus Grafit ist natürlich auch Quatsch.
Also diese drei Dings ist halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hat sich, sagen wir mal, in der Popkultur durchgesetzt. Und ja, die Tim und Stroh, von wann ist es noch mal Reiseziel Mond?
60.
Das muss irgendwie... Das ist 53. Also die ist sozusagen vor allen...
Vor Sputnik. Da steht's vier Jahre vor Sputnik.
Also irgendwie total super. Und sie ist einfach... Ich find sie bildhübsch. Also sie ist einfach so von den Proportionen her einfach wunderbar. Und ich denke, jeder, der von euch schon mal diese Comics gelesen hat, wird diese Rakete so meint. Und jetzt gibt es diese Rakete tatsächlich zu kaufen. Und sie stand halt, also nicht als funktionierende Rakete natürlich, aber sozusagen als so als Tischobjekt. Es gibt die in klein und es gibt die in mittelgroß und es gibt wahrscheinlich die auch in riesig.
Na so Gartengröße.
Bitte?
Also ich hatte die ja mal zum Aufboosten in 1,50 groß, ja. Hab ich verschenkt. Der Beschenkte hat sie auch fürchterlich gefreut, deswegen hab ich sie nicht mehr, aber es ist ja so, wenn man, wenn man ein 260 Mark! Wenn man ein Fan von Tim und Struppi oder Tantan, Emilou ist und es irgendwann mal in die Nähe von Brüssel schaffen sollte, sollte man dort auf jeden Fall ins Comic Museum gehen, Centre du BD, weil die haben teilweise Originale dort und der Gift Shop, der ist noch viel schlimmer, was einem da alles so in die.
Nähe von Brüssel gibt, gibt es noch eine große, eine 55-cm-Version, ich finde aber nur eine, die nicht aussieht wie die Rakete, von daher gilt das nicht. Die Rakete kostet halt irgendwie 130 Euro, das ist halt eine Strafgebühr, aber in so einem Impulskauf, während man gerade noch so Raketen inspiriert war...
Jenseits der Bankrott-Linie bist, aufgrund deines iPhone X, kommst du auf die Rakete dann auch nicht mehr an.
Das stimmt. Ist auf jeden Fall ein wunderschönes Objekt, hat genauso die richtige Schwere und macht sich super auf dem Tisch, oder?
Hier links.
Die sieht total geil aus und ich bin jetzt schon fast inspiriert, mal drüber nachzudenken, welchen Aufwand man treiben müsste, um die Fairy Dust mal in ähnlicher Form nachzuproduzieren.
Klick doch mal den Link und dann guck mal in dem ersten Foto auf der linken Seite, was für eine große Rakete da an der Treppe steht. Centre du BD Bruxelles.
Ja, übrigens steht, fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, eine, die ist gar nicht so groß hier, es steht eine noch größere Variante.
Nicht so groß, die ist locker drei Meter.
Ja, I repeat, eine noch größere Variante steht tatsächlich im Flughafen in Brüssel. Da haben sie irgendwie auch noch eine Rakete. Wissen wir mal, noch mal, Rocket Airport, Brussels, Brussels, Brussels. Vielleicht enttäuscht mich ja auch meine Erinnerung, aber nein, sie enttäuscht mich nicht. Und sie ist fucking groß, sie ist größer, sie ist vier Meter groß.
Okay, in Brüssel war ich noch nie auf dem Airport. Ich bin da immer mit dem Zug hingefahren.
Oh, hier ist ja eine Webseite nur mit Fotos von dieser. Nee, doch nicht. Ist das jetzt hier?
Bilder klicken ist, wie du das ausgefunden hast.
Ja, ich weiß, das zum Hören ist jetzt nicht so geil, aber ich tue das ja in den Chat. Und was im Chat ist, ist in den Show Notes. Und was in den Show Notes ist, ist gut für euch.
Ist gut für euch.
Außerdem musst du einen Affiliate-Link auf die Rakete jetzt platziert.
Werde ich dann sicherlich auch platziert haben. Im Chat ist das alles noch kostenlos.
Im Chat ist es noch kostenlos.
Okay, so, tolle Rakete. So, jetzt sind wir aber durch, oder?
Ich glaube, der Sack ist zu.
Ich hab jetzt keine brennenden Dinge mehr. Wir können gerne noch Sendezeit vollknallen. Mir jetzt egal, aber...
Nee, muss ja nicht.
Huckel ist ja nicht da.
Ja, ich bin auch langsam durch. Du hast mir vorhin noch was von deinem Hosting vorlieben berichtet.
Vorlieben? Ich hab halt mal, weil ich mal ein bisschen kurzfristig mal ein bisschen Zeit überbrücken musste und wieder mal auf der Suche war, wie sie alle Jahre mal, wo kann man denn jetzt mal was abwerfen. Wie ich ja vorhin schon erwähnte, gibt es ja so verschiedene Generationen von Dingen, was man tut. Du bist halt noch derjenige, der so Rechner zu Hause oder halt hier in der Meter-Ebene stapelt und die da laufen lässt. Dann gab es mal eine Zeit, wo man sozusagen seinen eigenen Rechner irgendwo hin gepackt hat. Mit dem üblichen Schmerz, dass er natürlich immer dann seine Netzteile oder sonstigen Ausfälle hat, während man 5000 Kilometer weiter im Urlaub war. Und natürlich gibt es jetzt schon seit Jahren diese Cloud-Dinger mit den üblichen Verdächtigen. 1&1, Strato, Hetzner, die üblichen Freaks. Und auch da kann man immer noch hosten oder Route-Server sich klicken oder sonst irgendwas. Aber was schon erstaunlich ist, ist, dass es da etliche Anbieter gibt, die unglaublich billig inzwischen sind mit diesen VMs. Aber es da natürlich technische Unterscheidungen gibt. Und ich hab mal wieder so ein bisschen rumgetestet Ende letzten Jahres und bin jetzt eigentlich schlussendlich bei Hetzner hängen geblieben. Weil, erstens sind sie sehr günstig. Sie haben jetzt gerade diese Woche oder letzte Woche noch mal so ein Pressrelease gemacht, dass sie jetzt nochmal ihr tolles Cloud-Angebot ganz günstig machen. Kannst du also die kleinste vor allem mit, keine Ahnung, 2 GB RAM einer CPU für 2,59 Euro im Monat klicken mit 20 TB Treffig.
20 TB Treffig für 3 Euro.
Dafür baue ich 2,59 Euro. So viel Zeit muss sein. Dafür baue ich mir jetzt keine eigene Hardware mehr zusammen. Echt nicht. Entschuldigung, 2,49 Euro. Eine CPU, 2 GB RAM, 20 GB Virtual Disk Space, 20 TB Treffig. Da kannst du auch mit 2 CPUs 4 GB RAM haben für 94. Ich könnte euch alles selber durchlesen auf der Seite. Aber es sind Kampfpreise. Was mir auf der Nerd-Seite daran gefällt, muss ich sagen, erstmal zappeln die nicht rum mit V6. Das ist halt einfach so da, fertig, zack. Zweitens, sie geben dir wirklich eine virtuelle Maschine basierend auf den üblichen Verdächtigen. Also da haben wir irgendwie einen Linux drunter und dann da die üblichen Dinger. Das heißt, du kannst auch selber die virtuelle Platte formatieren und dein eigenes Fallsystem drauf zu machen. Ich bin ja so ein Fan von ZFS wie eigentlich alle hier. Ich setze das aber jetzt nicht unter BSD ein, sondern unter Linux. Und ich baue mir auch spätestens seit 1604 LTS Ubuntu baue ich mir die Dinge auch mit ZFS-Root. Also nur mit einem ZFS-Fallsystem. Das geht, weil du halt bei Hetzner die nackte virtuelle Kiste kriegst. Da kannst du halt da machen, was du willst. Die haben auch so einen Recovery-Modus, wo du dann von außen wieder herankannst mit der Konsole oder das Ding wieder platt machen kannst. Aber das ist nicht so wie zum Beispiel bei Strato. Strato hat da so diese irgendwie Plex oder irgendeine andere Lösung im Spiel, wo sie dir ein Fallsystem bloß einblenden in deine Ubuntu-Kiste. Das heißt, du kannst sie nicht selber installieren, sondern du kriegst halt eine vorinstallierte Ubuntu-Kiste. Die kannst du zwar befummeln, aber immer wenn dem Strato irgendwas nicht passt, setzt er einfach Dinge in diesem Fallsystem wieder um. Zum Beispiel für, ich hab keine Aktien im Fallsystem, ich will doch bloß mal eben schnell meinen Java-Shit laufen lassen, was super Sache ist, aber eben nicht, wenn man, wie ich gerne da, ZFS oder so was drauf laufen lassen will. Und das ist wie gesagt ein Kampfpreis. Ich hab jetzt schon, noch bevor diese neuen Preise rauskamen, geklickt, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, was meine VM da kostet, aber das ist auch alles einstellig. Einstellig Euro im Monat. Und funktioniert ganz ordentlich. Also ich kann dir jetzt nichts sagen. Die Strato-Dinger haben auch gute Connectivity gehabt, aber eben du kannst, du bist sehr eingesperrt in die Systeme, die sie dort vorgeben. Also in diese Betriebssysteme, weil sie halt eben ihr virtuelles Fallsystem dort einblenden und also Zeugs machen. Und momentan wie gesagt nutze ich den Hetzner für so lauter kleine Maschinen.
Mit der Ebene läuft ja auch bei Hetzner.
Ahja, welcher Teil? Jetzt nicht dein CDN-Teil, sondern oder doch? Die Webseite. Du hast ja mal deine Webseite und dann hast du deinen RSS-Feed für deine Podcasts und so weiter.
Alles eine Büchse.
Da sind auch die Daten drauf?
Ja, da sind auch die Daten drauf.
Okay, und was hast du da? Hast du da irgendwie einen...
Sag ich so einen...
Rod-Server oder...
So einen 114 Euro Rod-Server-Ding sie mit irgendwie, kann viel und schnell und hat alles und viel Platte.
Und auch ein virtuelles Gigabit-Internet?
Ja.
Das ist übrigens auch nicht so, wenn du dich um... Nicht Standard.
Also ein virtuelles, also ich hoffe, es ist auch ein wichtiges Gigabit.
Es gibt jede Menge Hosts da, auch günstige und billige oder wie auch immer in Deutschland, die ich alle durchprobiert habe oder eben nicht durchprobiert habe, weil das findest du teilweise nicht auf der Webseite. Die erzählen ja was von Traffic oder sonst irgendwie und dann guckst du mal ganz genau nach und stellst fest, ach, die geben dir nur ein virtuelles 100-Megabit-Netz.
Ich meine, du hast jetzt Content. Ich hab so viel Traffic, den könnte ich mit 100 Megabit überhaupt nicht abbilden.
Aber da musst du eben auch drauf achten. Also man muss eben diese Details. Es geht jetzt nicht immer darauf, wie viel CPUs habe ich und was kostet mich das Ding im Monat oder so, sondern auch solche Parameter gibt es halt eben V6, gibt es V4, gibt es irgendwelche Traffic-Einschränkungen, wie wird das abgerechnet und was hab ich halt eben. Ich hab keine Content-Dinger bei mir drauf, also ich muss jetzt nicht Podcasts verteilen, aber ich finde es schon ganz sexy, dass ich mal zum Beispiel einen Burst machen kann, um mal was hochzuladen oder runterzuladen und dann halt eben da eben auch das Gigabit habe und nicht bloß 100 Megabit.
Ja, nee, also ich hab Sustain-Traffic.
Ja, ist mir klar.
Ich weiß nicht, ich komm locker auf über 20 Terabyte im Monat.
Die kannst du auch noch durch 100 Megabyte durchprügeln.
Ich hab auch zuletzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal geguckt. Immer wenn ich die Freak Show release kriege, kriege ich irgendwie so Warnings mit irgendwie so meine momentanen Traffic-Grenzen, also die ich mir jetzt selber gesetzt habe, nur mal zu sehen, dass was passiert und so. Ist immer ganz lustig. Ich brauchte einfach mal so ein Provider, wo ich einfach mal gepflegt durchatmen konnte. Also ich brauchte einfach so eine kleine Limits-Maschine, wo ich alles draufpacken kann.
Wie heißt die jetzt? Metaebene.fm oder fe oder?
Me.
Metaebene.
Me wie Metaebene.
Stimmt, Hetzner, sieht man. 2-A-0-1-4-F-8. Das erwähne ich jetzt mal deswegen, weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat sich Hetzner mal vor ein paar Jahren so ein Schmuddelkind-Ding eingetreten. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht hätten sie auch Support sorgen oder sowas. Es gibt so Leute, wenn du dich mit Leuten unterhältst, ich hab mein Haus bei Hetzner, dann trümpfen die mir die Nase. Bei Hetzner? Scheißladen. Aber ich kann das nicht sagen. Die haben eine schöne Oberfläche, Robot, viel schneller. Bei Strato, die wollten erst mal wissen, wie lange... Also, ich konnte nicht einfach in eine Maschine klicken, sondern da bin ich dann erst mal kontaktiert worden oder so von denen. Da sitzt noch ein Human, der da screened. Das mag auch Gründe haben, ich will das jetzt gar nicht beurteilen. Aber das ist halt nicht so dieses Cloud-Ding. Und der Hetzner wirbt halt damit, dass du deine Maschinen jetzt, gerade in diesem Cloud-Setup, die haben so einen Monatspreis, der gilt aber nur dann, wenn du den Ding einen Monat benutzt. Wenn du dir jetzt mal eben eine VM klickst oder eine clones, du kannst die auch clone, du kannst da sagen, hast du eine, die willst du jetzt gerne noch fünf davon haben, nehmen wir an, du hast jetzt deinen Meta eben ein Ding, du stellst fest, dass die heutige Sendung ein unglaublicher Renner ist. Und dann kannst du einfach deine Kröte da nochmal clone. Jetzt vielleicht nicht mit deinem Reelserver, aber wenn du so ein Cloud-Ding hast, und so ein Ding starten und nur mal für zwölf Stunden laufen lassen. So denken die Leute mit diesem Cloud-Zeugs inzwischen. Das heißt, es gibt halt eben auch so Cent- oder Bruchteile von Cent-Preisen für CPUs, Memory, lalala und so. Beziehungsweise, das macht der Hetzner nicht so flexibel. Das hast du so beim Amazon oder beim Google hast du solche Preise. Aber wenn du dir das hier anguckst, genau draufschaut auf so ein Ding. Genau, diese Maschine, die ich vorhin sagte, die 2,49 Euro im Monat kostet, das ist der Maximalpreis, eigentlich kostet die 0,004 Euro pro Stunde. Also 0,04 Cent pro Stunde. Das heißt, du kannst sie kurzfristig mal eine generieren oder eine Clone, die du schon hast, also sozusagen verteilen oder wenn du deine Software entsprechend aufgesetzt hast, sozusagen ein bisschen in die Breite gehen, parallelisieren und wenn du es nicht mehr brauchst, faltest du es wieder ein. Das geht eben so schnell, auch mit einer API. Das kannst du also automatisch auch machen. Du musst ja nicht als User auf so einer Web-Oberfläche nur rumklicken, sondern machst du bei einer API und generierst da deine Maschinen, so wie das halt der Amazon, der Google auch macht.
Auf so einer Plattform war ich ja vorher auch hier, bei einem coolen Ding, wo ich vorher war.
Die haben aber keine API, das musst du von Hand klicken.
Ja, und das wurde dann auch schnell teurer, wenn da Platten dabei sind. Und ich brauch halt viel Platten, ich will halt so zu BU-mäßig genug Luft haben, RAM auch, und so wird es dann schnell teurer mit diesen Virtual Ink. Also wurde es zumindest schnell teurer, jetzt ist natürlich wieder alles ein bisschen entspannter. Ja, und insofern bin ich jetzt erstmal ganz zufrieden, weil seitdem das so läuft, läuft es super. Ich habe wenig Probleme, was aber auch daran liegt, dass ich einen Top-Admin am Start habe und es nicht mehr selber mache. Das hilft schon mal enorm.
Hast du da drauf Linux oder BSD?
Früh BSD, mit auch so ZFS, das volle Programm. Und halt irgendwie alle Domains sind da drauf.
Aber das ist immer noch eine bestimmte Maschine. Du musst selber deine Backups machen, wenn die kaputt geht, musst du nachts anrufen, musst du einen von den Hetzner in seinem Rechenzentrum scheuchen, der dir da eine neue Maschine für hinbucht, oder die repariert. Das ist halt der Vorteil.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau, wie der Support-Fall so genau aussieht, aber im Kern ist es halt so ein dedicated Server.
Mein Pro-Tipp wäre, mach mal mit dir selber eine Übung. Machs vielleicht nicht nackt, weil die ketzner Leute wollen vielleicht auch mal pennen, obwohl da immer Leute in den Rechenzentren rumrennen. Ich kenn die Rechenzentren, ich war da schon drin in so einem Ding. Aber die, ja, dass du einfach mal sagst, du klonst dir mal deine, oder sowas, und probierst damit mal das ganze Spiel durch, wie recoverst du das eigentlich? Weil das willst du, Murphy sorgt dafür, dass das garantiert passiert, während du im Kourou bist. Ja, da ist... Dein 30G-LTE-Level von O2 gerade am Anschlag. Und so, weißt du, da wird schon dafür gesorgt, dass das ordentlich schief geht. Und deswegen ist es vielleicht gar nicht schlecht, wenn man das mal ausprobiert hat.
Na gut, da vertraue ich voll...
Dollar Admin.
Dollar Admin, kann man auch mal sagen, ist niemand anderes als Sebastian Reimers, der ja auch das Studio Link zusammenhackt. Der ist nämlich in seinem Hauptberuf vor allem erstmal Top Admin und da... Da wird einem geholfen. Da ist sozusagen die Betreuungsqualität ganz oben, falls ihr mal so richtig ordentlich gehostet und betreut haben wollt und das auch funktioniert.
Ja, das ist ja echt immer noch ein Thema. Kurzfristig Maschinen irgendwo abzuwerfen, ist ja relativ easy heutzutage Traffic irgendwo mal abzuschmeißen. Die Leute klagen immer, Deutschland wäre so ein Internetlochland und so was, aber in den Rechenzentren und dort, wo es eine Glasfaser gibt, brummt das schon ganz ordentlich. Da ist jetzt nichts zu meckern. Gerade dieser Tage habe ich ein Angebot bekommen für ein Projekt von einem größeren Tier-1-Carrier. Wenn du dich halt in so einem Rechenzentrum bewegst, nicht zu jemandem nach Hause, da musst du immer noch die letzte Meile, aber dann hängst du jetzt in irgendeinem von diesen enden Rechenzentrum rum, die wir in Deutschland oder auch in Berlin haben. Und es ist ein Tier-1-Provider, das heißt, du kriegst komplette V6 und V4-Kollektivität global. Ich sag dir jetzt, ich will jetzt gerade mal einen Preis ansagen, was du bei uns tust. Da schmeißt du jetzt eine Maschine ab, wird es jetzt sozusagen einfach treffig da. Nicht eine Maschine, schmeißt du eine Route ab. Und die rufen das auf, ohne zu verhandeln, für 230 Euro für einen Gig voll flat.
Treffig. Ein Gigabit Treffig.
Voll flat. Mit einem Routing. Das ist noch viel teurer. Also ein Gigabit Interface pro Sekunde Gigabit.
Ich dachte, das wird hier schon gigabyte.
Das geht auch noch billiger, gibt es beim Hurricane Elect noch für 170 oder 170 Dollar. Aber das ist, ähm, 10G, wenn du mit Leuten ankommst, mit 1G lächeln die dich alle nur noch an, weil die haben in ihren Routern kaum noch 1G Interfaces. Oder in ihren Switches. Und, wie gesagt, an einem bestimmten zentralen Punkt mal so ein bisschen Bits zu kriegen, wie man einfach mal so rumsaunen kann, ist heutzutage kein Thema mehr. Nur nicht in der Meta-Ebene, solange du hier kein Glas hast. Aber du willst jetzt hier auch keinen File-Saver betreiben oder hier keinen Content-Saver, ehrlich nicht. Weil du kannst dir die Kondition gar nicht schaffen, um so ein Ding ordentlich zu betreiben. Aber Sicherheit, Kühlung, Tralala und so, Stromverbrauch und so.
Nein, ich will ja auch keine Server betreiben. Ich will hier einfach nur schnell das Netz haben.
Hier werden Files created, nicht gesurft.
Ich will einfach, ich möchte einfach amtlich ins Netz reinatmen können.
Ausatmen willst du?
Auch ausatmen, weil wir einatmen, muss auch ausatmen. Aber du kannst mir das vielleicht ganz gut nachvollziehen. Ich finde halt einfach so, ich meine, dieses Internet und ich, wir sind schon ganz schön lange Freunde. Wir kommen gut klar miteinander.
Ich möchte jetzt gerne die Beziehung intensivieren.
Wir standen uns schon immer nahe. Es ist nur so, dass immer was zwischen uns war. Es gab immer so Leute, die der Meinung waren, dass ich meine Beziehung zum Internet nicht so ausleben darf, wie er mir vielleicht manchmal danach ist. Das heißt ja nicht, dass man sich den ganzen Tag anruft. Aber manchmal hat man sich ja schon mal was zu erzählen. Und dann finde ich, soll nicht irgendjemand dazwischenspringen und sagen, aber Paragraph hast du nicht gesehen und Pipapo und hier. Da sag ich einfach nur, geht mir aus der Sonne. Ich will jetzt hier zu meiner Fernbeziehung. Und ich möchte da einfach mal unkondimisiert einfach reinkommunizieren.
Und Singapur ist auch schön.
Du weißt auch...
10G für 120 Dollar.
Es ist so ein mega Unterschied, ob man jetzt mit so einem Internet über so ein Modem oder irgendein so ein asynchrones Scheiß kommuniziert. Oder ob man halt einfach mal...
Symmetrisch.
Symmetrisch reinkommuniziert. Wenn man einfach zu viel hat, also wenn es einfach keinerlei Grenzen gibt, an die man so ranstößt erstmal.
Du findest denn die anderen Grenzen.
Ja, das ist ja okay, man kann ja dann...
Wenn du jetzt hier Jengig in den Po steckst, dann ist alles... Keine Beziehung ist auf Bauer unproblematisch. 99% des Internets damit gar nicht klarkommt, dass du Jengig am Start hast.
Ja, aber Hänsel willst zu Gretel und das muss irgendwie alles sein.
Verstehe.
Wie hießen die beiden in Meten, die getrennt waren?
Konnten zueinander nicht finden.
Ja, wer war das noch gleich?
Das waren doch welche Königskinder.
Königskinder, genau. Wie zwei Königskinder sind wir. Das Internet und ich.
Du, Internet ist wie Verkehrsunfall. Du willst nicht, dass das Problem auf deiner Seite ist.
Mir ist das alles klar. Ihr wisst, dass das mein Business ist und mein Field of Expertise. Aber ich stell halt eben auch immer wieder fest, dass wahnsinnig viel getrommelt wird, wo dann wirklich auch nicht wirklich so ein Need dahinter ist. Ich will hier mal kurz nur einen Punkt erwähnen, dem mich so ein bisschen nachdenklich stimmt. Bei dieser ganzen Diskussion und die bösen Telcos, allen voran natürlich, die Telekom. Sie gibt uns ja kein Glas und sie gibt uns kein LTE. Also ja, LTE schon, aber teuer. Und sie soll doch jetzt gefälligst mal die LTE-Flatrate anmachen und uns ein Glas legen. Und da hab ich zum Beispiel auch so ein bisschen, denn fehlt mir denn Verständnis, weil man sieht ja jetzt schon, was passiert. In anderen Bereichen, die Leute haben ja so Otto Normal, Hipster. In Berlin hat ja kein Festnetz-Telefon mehr. Ja, also genauso sieht es aus, wenn das LTE plötzlich umsonst ist und die LTE-Advance fahren, oder 5G oder sonst irgendwas, oder nicht umsonst, sondern Flatrate ist, dann hat doch keiner mehr Glas zu Hause. Warum? Und dann ist natürlich die Forderung, da hinzugehen, sagen, investiert doch bitte mal ein paar Milliarden, dass hier überall Glas in der Straße liegt, aber baut auch gleichzeitig das LTE so aus, dass wir das Glas gar nicht mehr brauchen. Zwar kann ich verstehen, man fordert ja immer erstmal was, aber ich kann auch verstehen, dass dann jemand bei der Telekom so ein Bienenkont da mal sagt, so hust, das dreschnet sich aber nicht für uns.
Ich fordere nicht, dass die Telekom überall Glas legt, ich fordere, dass die Bundesrepublik Deutschland überall Glas legt.
Ja, genau, das ist was vollkommen anderes. Aber das fordern eben nicht viele Leute. Wenn du dir die Schreihölzer anguckst, die springen ja mal drauf. Wenn ein Telekom-Mann vor der Presse tritt und wieder ein Dosiegel-Announcement macht, dann springen die auf die Bühne mit Transparenten und Rauchbomben. Und warum legt ihr denn nicht endlich überall Glas?
Wenn ein Telekom-Mann sagt, Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist nicht genug, dann kann man schon noch mal draufhauen.
Ja, das find ich vollkommen okay. Ich muss mal sagen, die Leute sollten auch mal begreifen, dass immer wirklich jetzt Staat und Kirche trennen. Also dass sie dann sagen, wenn ihr alle glaubt, es ist wichtig für unser Land und unsere Infrastruktur, dann haut doch bitte endlich die Politikern in die Fresse und lasst die Unternehmen in Ruhe. Aber gut, da waren wir schon ein paar Mal.
Außerdem, was ich noch anbringen wollte, leitungsgebundenes Netz ist immer zwei Größenordnungen schneller als das, was über Funk geht. Und deswegen...
Ja, aber schneller irgendwann bist du... Du musst... Ja, bisher haben wir es immer geschafft, Technologien einzuholen. Der berühmte Spruch, so mit 640 Kilobyte sind da wohl genug für einen Rechner und so. Ist das übliches Spiel. Und natürlich kann man den Leuten jetzt, die Pressefreaks von diesen Telcos, kann man auch mal frech ins Gesicht grinsen, wenn sie sagen, die Leute wissen ja gar nicht, was sie machen sollen mit einem Gigabit. Ja, bau doch mal eins, keine Sorge, das kriegen wir schon voll. Aber nichtsdestotrotz passiert sowas immer auch in Schritten. Ja, also selbst wenn du jetzt einfach mal Deutschland komplett mit Gigabit, die ist ja nicht Segen ist, das wird erst mal eine Weile vor sich hin eiern. Irgendwann werden wir das einholen. Ja, wenn sich dafür nur genug Applikationen finden. Wenn wir jetzt 360 Grad Videos in 8K haben.
Der Punkt ist ja, dass die Applikationen nicht in Deutschland entstehen werden, wenn wir nicht die Infrastruktur haben, die diese Applikationen unterstützen.
Ich verstehe das, ich will das ja auch haben. Ich will das auch aus einem anderen Grund haben, weil ich es für die stabilere Zukunft halte. Auch was Klima angeht. Ich habe auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass die ganzen Kupfernetze jetzt immer dreimal im Jahr baden gehen wegen Sturm und Überschwemmung. Das ist ja auch so ein Problemchen, was man da noch nicht so auf dem Sturm hat. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, du wirst es genauer sehen, die Leute, die jetzt sagen, ich habe keinen Festnetz mehr, ich habe doch mein Handy, weil die haben genau das selbe Problem. Die werden auch sagen, wieso, ich habe doch 5G in meinem Laptop. Was soll ich mir jetzt hier zu Hause noch einen Router hinstellen für eine Leitung?
Na ja, gut, ich meine, wenn du Festnetz sagst, meinst du jetzt Telefonie, oder?
Nein, das ist als Beispiel, wie das da schon gelaufen ist. Wo du halt einfach sagst, ja, es gibt halt jetzt eine Wireless-Technologie, die vollkommen, eben wirklich teilweise sogar besser ist, als das, was du so als Festnetz kriegst, so das Telefon von Oma oder sowas. Deswegen falten sie das ja auch alles ein, mit dem ganzen Gewöhn, was das gehört.
Ja, aber nur weil wir halt irgendwo bei 50 MBit stehen geblieben sind und LTE jetzt genauso viel kann, heißt es ja noch lange nicht, dass jetzt 50 MBit viel sind. Also ich verstehe die Argumentation jetzt nicht ganz.
Ich hab ja mehr als 50 MBit LTE. Du nicht?
Weiß ich nicht, wie viel da durchkommt.
Du hast noch keinen Gig LTE, aber du kannst Gig auch mit LTE bauen, mit LTE Advanced und so. Und der Ausbau von so einem Mobilfunknetz ist viel, viel einfacher, als jetzt in jeden scheiß Haushalt, in jeden Hausaufgang hin und her, da Zeugs reinzulegen. Von daher nochmal, ich möchte das auch haben, aber ich verstehe das, dass die Leute, die das denn machen sollen, die aufgefordert werden, das zu machen, aber nicht hier, hier heißt es ein Geld-Bau mal, das würde die Telekom oder jeder andere Provider auch gerne machen, sondern die sagen ja, baut doch mal auf eure Kosten. Wir wollen das gerne haben, aber ihr bitte, tut ihr jetzt mal euer Geld dafür rein, dass das so ist. Und dass da denn irgendjemand...
Nee, das ist ja Unsinn.
Dass da irgendein Buchhalter sitzt, der sagt so, Moment mal, das ist halt zumindest für nachvollziehbar.
Nee, das halt ich ja vor, das ist ja Unsinn. Also wenn man so eine große Infrastrukturleistung erbringen will, dann muss die von Staatsseite aus passieren und nicht aus... Damit es neutral ist. Aus einem privaten Unternehmen. Also das ist ja zu erwarten, dass ein privater Unternehmen das tut. Gut, es gibt einige Ausnahmen, aber das ist nicht die Regel. Schau dir die Autoindustrie an. Die wollen auch alle keine Ladeinfrastruktur bauen.
Aber auch da hat man übrigens immer noch nicht verstanden, dass das öffentliche Aufgabe sein könnte irgendwann mal. Nach dem Motto, wir haben ja auch noch nie Tankstellen gebaut. Warum sollen wir jetzt Ladesäulen bauen? Da wird es auch wieder auf private Leute geschoben.
Das wird ja gefordert, aber es läuft halt wieder so. Es gibt Förderungen dafür, dass dann private Leute Infrastruktur haben müssen, weil es innenrissig ist.
Die Diskussion hatten wir schon ein paar Mal.
Genau, wir machen den Sack zu. Dann musst du jetzt den Abspann spielen.
Wir können ja erst noch mal Tschüss sagen.
Aber bevor wir Tschüss sagen.
Jetzt auf jeden Fall nachdem, also jetzt ein bisschen ruppig hat es angefangen mit viel drei Wochen Abständen und so. Jetzt denke ich mal, ist die nächste Zeit erstmal wieder alles mit zwei Wochen Abstand. Bis wieder die krassen Reisereien anfangen oder andere Zwänge von außen kommen.
Kourou!
Freuen wir, genau, weil sie wieder nach Kourou muss oder welche anderen Raketen abfangen müssen. Und ja, ansonsten freuen wir uns darauf, dass Dennis und Huckel und alle anderen wieder gesund und ausreichend sich wieder hier reintegrieren und dann kann eigentlich alles nur noch total toll werden. Und ja, insofern würde ich sagen, können wir der Sache den letzten Schubs geben. Kauft euch auf jeden Fall so eine Tintin-Rakete. Die ist so schön.
Ja, und passt auf beim Straßenverkehr.
Genau, vor allem vor Verbrennern.
Vor Verbrennern.
Ihr wisst Bescheid, also tschüss, bis bald!